Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode number nine, HTML and CSS. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so it's been a little bit of a delay since the last show, but we were both really busy doing some pretty awesome stuff. I went to a conference, the Gecko Conference in Ireland.
本节目由Host Tornado赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第九期，HTML和CSS。Jason，开始吧。嘿，距离上一期节目已经过去了一段时间，但我们俩最近都在忙着做一些非常棒的事情。我去参加了一个会议，在爱尔兰举办的Gecko会议。
That tops my excuse of doing random chores around the house. But okay, fine, be a show-off. I think you had a house catastrophe to attend to, which is pretty interesting. catastrophe to attend to oh yeah just a little bit of water stuff on my wall get to learn how to fix it not just a nerd but uh did you use like instructables or anything like that or do you just have natural like google like how to fix water damage on your wall oh yeah this goes back to our talk a couple episodes again you've probably used youtube and saw somebody else exactly yeah so it's pretty it's actually fairly straightforward it's just hard to match the texture because have all this industrial equipment they use when they do it initially and then it's really hard to make it look like that again yeah like because when they when they paint your walls
这比我做些家务活的借口要强多了。好吧，行，算你炫耀。我想你当时家里出了点状况需要处理，这挺有意思的。需要处理的灾难，哦，是的，墙上渗了点水，我得学学怎么修补它，不仅仅是个书呆子。呃，你用了像Instructables之类的网站吗？还是你只是用了像谷歌搜索“如何修复墙壁水渍”这种自然的方法？哦，是的，这回到了我们几期前谈论的话题，你可能用了YouTube，看到了别人是怎么做的，没错，确实是这样。其实这相当简单，只是很难匹配纹理，因为他们最初做的时候用的是工业设备，之后很难让它看起来和原来一样。是的，因为当他们粉刷墙壁时，
they like spray and so blotches show up but when you use a brush it's like you get streaks instead it's like smooth or yeah yeah yeah yeah but anyways yeah boring okay ireland so see ireland was great the conference was awesome um i went the conference was gecko which stands for genetic evolutionary computation conference and uh since a bunch of guys who are interested in genetic algorithms and neuroevolution, which is my focus. And it's basically a way to sort of get computers to, you know, through trial and error to sort of adapt to their environment. So, you know, in the same way as we adapted as human beings and plants and animals continue to adapt today to their environment, you know, we want to write computer programs that, you know, might not really know the answer right away, but through adaptation, you know,
他们会用喷涂，所以会出现斑点，但当你用刷子时，你会留下条纹，看起来很平滑，或者……是的，是的，是的。但不管怎样，好吧，无聊的话题。爱尔兰，爱尔兰很棒，会议也很棒。嗯，我去参加的会议是Gecko，代表遗传进化计算会议（Genetic Evolutionary Computation Conference）。呃，那里有一群对遗传算法和神经进化感兴趣的人，这也是我的研究重点。它基本上是一种让计算机通过试错来适应环境的方法。所以，就像我们人类、植物和动物今天继续适应环境一样，我们想编写一些计算机程序，它们可能一开始并不知道答案，但通过适应，
two parent programs can make a baby program that's a little bit better at solving the task. You should ask your parents about that. Yeah. So the stork brings better and better solutions. It's kind of interesting. Yeah. Yeah, that sounds pretty cool. So that sounds pretty cool so that sounds
两个父代程序可以产生一个在解决任务方面稍微好一点的子代程序。你应该问问你的父母关于这个的问题。是的。所以送子鸟带来了越来越好的解决方案。这挺有趣的。是的。是的，听起来很酷。所以这听起来很酷，所以这听起来
pretty nerdy were there uh was it good conversations and cool people to hang out with yeah definitely i want to plug one thing which uh so i made an algorithm as part of my phd dissertation called hyper neat and uh like a neat freak algorithm yeah exactly it cleans your floor no it's a roomba so what it stands for a hyper cube neuroevolution of augmenting topologies but that's neither here nor there the important thing is it um someone took this algorithm and used it to generate a 3d model maker and uh he actually had a bunch of these 3d models that he created with a 3D printer. And you can actually go on this website and evolve your own 3D models.
挺书呆子的。那里有好的对话和很酷的人可以交流吗？是的，绝对有。我想宣传一件事，我作为博士论文的一部分编写了一个算法，叫做HyperNEAT，就像一个“整洁怪”（neat freak）算法。是的，没错，它能打扫你的地板。不，那是Roomba。它代表“增强拓扑的超立方体神经进化”（Hypercube Neuroevolution of Augmenting Topologies），但这不重要。重要的是，有人采用了这个算法并用它来生成一个3D模型制作器，他实际上用3D打印机制作了一堆他创造的3D模型。你实际上可以去这个网站，进化出你自己的3D模型。
And I thought this was really interesting and super fun. Let me see if I can find the link here. Ta-da, ta-da. I know it was on my Google Buzz. Oh, here it is. So yeah, the link is www.endlessforms.com. That's all one word. Endlessforms.com.
我觉得这真的很有趣，超级好玩。让我看看能不能找到链接。当当，当当。我知道它在我的Google Buzz上。哦，在这儿。所以，链接是www.endlessforms.com。都是一个词。Endlessforms.com。
So we'll put a link in the blog and all that good stuff. But yeah, you can go on there and you can actually take two parent objects and make baby objects and do mutation and stuff like that and grow your own sort of crazy object. And then you can even, for a small fee, have them print it and mail it to you, which I think was really interesting. And they also found a bunch of bugs in my code and stuff, which is kind of useful.
我们会把链接放在博客里，还有所有那些好东西。但确实，你可以去那里，你可以拿两个父对象，制造出子对象，进行变异之类的操作，培育出你自己的那种疯狂对象。然后你甚至可以支付一小笔费用，让他们打印出来并邮寄给你，我觉得这非常有趣。他们还在我的代码里发现了一堆漏洞之类的东西，这还挺有用的。
So although I don't know how useful it is now, but at any rate, yeah, the conference was great. It was fascinating to talk to some of the people there. And it was also very interesting to go around Ireland. As many people know, Ireland's been the source of strife between, you know, Protestants and Catholics. And one of the things that, you know, my wife and I did was take a bus tour through Northern Ireland. And we saw a lot of the places where the conflicts happened. And actually, as recently as 1997, the area was a militarized zone. And there were many places like, you know, cathedrals and even whole cities that civilians weren't really meant to,
所以虽然我不知道它现在有多大用处，但无论如何，会议很棒。和那里的一些人交谈非常迷人。而且去爱尔兰各地看看也非常有趣。正如许多人所知，爱尔兰一直是新教徒和天主教徒之间冲突的源头。我和我妻子做的一件事就是乘坐巴士游览北爱尔兰。我们看到了很多冲突发生的地方。事实上，就在1997年，该地区还是一个军事化区域。有很多地方，比如大教堂，甚至整个城市，平民并不是真的被允许，
weren't, you know, outside tourists weren't really meant to visit and weren't supposed to visit. And around 1997, they opened everything up and demilitarized Northern Ireland. And so it was fascinating to see. You know, there's a lot of culture there, and it was very interesting. That sounds pretty good.
并不是，你知道，外来的游客并不是真的被允许访问，也不应该访问。大约在1997年，他们开放了一切，并将北爱尔兰非军事化。所以看到这些非常迷人。你知道，那里有很多文化，而且非常有趣。听起来很不错。
Had you been there before? No, this was the first first time for me so uh awesome yeah the bus tour really kind of kind of made it happen um because otherwise you know even though we speak the language and everything it's europe is just vastly different you know so yeah um they drive on the left side of the road and all those things so yeah i definitely wouldn't have been comfortable driving myself from southern to northern ireland well not nearly as cool as going to ireland but i saw uh the humble indie bundle number three is out yeah and uh so i i guess this is a group of independent game publishers i guess it's
你以前去过那里吗？没有，这是我第一次去。所以，太棒了。巴士旅行确实让这一切变得很真实，因为否则，你知道，即使我们说同样的语言，欧洲也完全不同。所以，是的，他们靠道路左侧行驶，诸如此类。所以，是的，我绝对不会有信心自己从南爱尔兰开车到北爱尔兰。好吧，虽然不如去爱尔兰那么酷，但我看到Humble Indie Bundle 3发布了。是的，我想这是一群独立游戏发行商，我想是
a a group of people who work with independent game publishers to get some games together. And it's almost always cross-platform. So it works on OSX, Linux, and Windows. And they bundle them together and sell them in a pay-what-you-want style of sell. So you can pay, you know, I assume as little as a penny. I don't know what the exact minimum is. All the way up to, you know, some people pay thousands of dollars for the bundle. And then you can, one really cool thing about it is, well, there's lots of really cool things. But one of them is that you have little sliders and you can set how much of what you pay goes to the developers of the game, the developers of the package, like the people putting it all together and hosting the website and that stuff. And then they have two charities that they support, the Electronic Frontiers Foundation,
一群与独立游戏发行商合作，将一些游戏整合在一起的人。而且它几乎总是跨平台的。所以它可以在OSX、Linux和Windows上运行。他们把它们捆绑在一起，以“随心所欲支付”的方式出售。所以你可以支付，我想，哪怕是一分钱。我不知道确切的最低限额是多少。一直到，你知道，有些人为这个捆绑包支付数千美元。然后，其中一个非常酷的事情是，嗯，有很多非常酷的事情。但其中之一是你有小滑块，你可以设置你支付的金额中有多少比例给游戏开发者、包的开发者，比如那些把所有东西放在一起并托管网站的人等等。然后他们支持两个慈善机构，电子前沿基金会（Electronic Frontiers Foundation），
or Freedom, sorry, I messed that up. And then Child's Play. So I know you, you're a big Electronic Frontier Foundation supporter, right? Yeah, definitely. So the Humble Indie Bundle is great. I do it every year and I put a lot of the slider towards the EFF just because it's something that I strongly believe in. You can really, as Patrick mentioned, set the sliders
或者自由（Freedom），抱歉，我搞错了。还有Child's Play。所以我知道你，你是电子前沿基金会的大力支持者，对吧？是的，绝对是。所以Humble Indie Bundle很棒。我每年都参与，而且我把滑块的大部分比例都给了EFF，因为这是我坚信的东西。你真的可以，正如Patrick提到的，设置滑块
and the proportions of your donation however you want. But they're usually pretty quality games especially considering you can name your price. They're usually pretty quality games, especially considering you can name your price. They're definitely high quality games for the value. And they distribute them through Steam, which is really useful. So you don't have to deal with, you know, as long as you're a Steam member, you don't have to deal with downloading the XE and going through the install shield and making sure it's on all your computers and things like that.
以及你捐款的比例，随你喜欢。但它们通常是相当高质量的游戏，特别是考虑到你可以自己定价。它们绝对是物有所值的优质游戏。而且他们通过Steam分发，这非常有用。所以你不必处理，你知道，只要你是Steam会员，你就不必处理下载EXE文件，通过安装向导，并确保它在你所有的电脑上都能运行之类的事情。
And I think the last few times they've even open sourced the games. Yeah, I think some of them have been open sourced. I don't think they've open sourced all of them. Yep, so you can look at the source code, which is kind of cool. And one thing that they all have in common is they don't use any DRM. So no digital rights management. So what that means is that you actually own the thing, you actually own the thing that you bought, you know, no one can take it from you. So. Yeah. And Child's Play, um, just if, if people don't know what that is, uh, is a charity where they try to install,
而且我认为过去几次他们甚至开源了这些游戏。是的，我想其中一些已经开源了。我不认为他们把所有游戏都开源了。是的，所以你可以查看源代码，这很酷。而且它们都有一个共同点，就是它们不使用任何DRM。所以没有数字版权管理。这意味着你实际上拥有你购买的东西，没有人能把它从你手中夺走。所以。是的。还有Child's Play，嗯，如果人们不知道那是什么，是一个慈善机构，他们试图在医院里安装，
you know, game consoles or video games of various sorts to hospitals for, um, people who are, you know, kind of in the hospital for extended periods of time to have something to do um and to kind of help them with that so yeah the games for this year are uh crayon physics deluxe which is an awesome awesome game is one of my favorite games i actually already own it but i think i'll you know almost definitely buy it and play the whole thing again and uh just to put it simply, you could think of it as being a child, and you draw these objects on a piece of paper with your crayon, but they come to life. So if you draw, say, a circle, that circle turns into a boulder,
你知道，各种游戏机或视频游戏，为那些在医院里待很长时间的人提供一些事情做，并帮助他们度过难关。所以，今年的游戏有《蜡笔物理学豪华版》（Crayon Physics Deluxe），这是一款非常棒的游戏，是我最喜欢的游戏之一。其实我已经有了，但我认为我几乎肯定会再买一次，并把整个游戏再玩一遍。简单来说，你可以把它想象成你还是个孩子，你在纸上用蜡笔画出这些物体，但它们活了过来。所以如果你画一个圆，那个圆就会变成一块巨石，
and it falls down to the bottom of the page and starts rolling. And you can create all sorts of different objects and they act as you know boulders cantilevers uh you know you can make a car you can do all sorts of crazy things yeah it's kind of similar to like scribble knots meets the incredible machine yeah yeah it's got a lot of both but with drawing yeah yeah definitely um yeah cogs I've never played. Have you ever played that one? No, but it looked like it's a kind of 3D slider puzzle where you slide different tiles on various surfaces to align a set of cogs to enable a machine to run. It looked pretty interesting.
它会掉到页面底部并开始滚动。你可以创造各种各样的物体，它们的作用就像巨石、悬臂，你可以制造一辆车，你可以做各种疯狂的事情。是的，这有点像《涂鸦冒险家》（Scribblenauts）遇见《不可思议的机器》（The Incredible Machine）。是的，它两者都有，但加上了绘画。是的，绝对。嗯，是的，《Cogs》我从来没玩过。你玩过那个吗？没有，但它看起来像是一种3D滑块拼图，你在各种表面上滑动不同的瓷砖，以对齐一组齿轮，使机器能够运转。看起来很有趣。
Oh, nice. Yeah, V to the 5th is a platformer game. V, V, V, V, V, V, V. Is a platformer game. It's V to the 6th, right? Oh, you're right. I miscount i miscounted oh no now we insulted them oh man this is the first time we've been wrong on the podcast yeah only time so the um v to the fifth is a platformer game that's known for being so six for being especially difficult
哦，不错。是的，《VVVVVV》是一款平台游戏。V，V，V，V，V，V，V。是一款平台游戏。是V的6次方，对吧？哦，你是对的。我数错了，我数错了。哦不，现在我们冒犯他们了。天哪，这是我们第一次在播客上出错。是的，唯一的一次。所以，嗯，V的5次方是一款以特别困难而闻名的平台游戏。
and challenging and so um you know the thing about platformers is you can start, like usually there's many levels, and when you die, you just go back to that level. So you don't lose a lot from dying. But they make it very difficult, so you're constantly pushing yourself to, like, you know, get that one more level. So I've heard a lot of good things about it. I don't know the other two. Do you know the other two?
而且很有挑战性。所以，你知道，平台游戏的事情是你可以开始，通常有很多关卡，当你死的时候，你只是回到那一关。所以你不会因为死亡而损失太多。但他们让它变得非常困难，所以你不断地推动自己去，你知道，通过那多出来的一关。所以我听说了很多关于它的好评。我不知道另外两个。你知道另外两个吗？
No, but I know on that Vita the 6th, the guy who made Minecraft actually made one of the levels for it oh interesting yeah so um he he designed one of the levels and it looks it looks kind of hard it looks like one of those ones that kind of punishes your brain a little yeah a hammer hammer fight is some it's like a steampunk helicopter with medieval weapons you like fly around and destroy stuff oh that sounds awesome and then and yet it moves uh looking at the you know little demo video it looked like you kind of move through a world and you can kind of rotate the world around you so you're gonna always stay straight up but the world rotates around you to allow you to move
不知道，但我知道在那个V的6次方里，制作《我的世界》（Minecraft）的那个人实际上为它制作了其中一个关卡。哦，有趣。是的，所以他设计了其中一个关卡，看起来有点难，看起来像是那种会稍微惩罚你大脑的游戏。Hammerfight是某种蒸汽朋克直升机，带有中世纪武器，你可以飞来飞去摧毁东西。哦，那听起来太棒了。还有《And Yet It Moves》，看着那个小演示视频，看起来你可以在一个世界中移动，你可以旋转你周围的世界，所以你总是保持直立，但世界在你周围旋转，让你能够移动
through passages and stuff yeah i've actually played this one yeah so basically you know as most platformers you know you jump and you sort of navigate through the world and in this case it's sort of a little backwards where you're making the world move through you and uh yeah it's pretty fun yeah so check that out uh especially if you're a gamer or uh you know want to support a good cause or yeah yeah definitely so i think uh you have the linux kernel 3.0 is out which is which is really awesome for uh for geeks like us who uh it's been at two leading edge two for like a long time two dot stuff yeah i mean it was i think like uh if i remember correctly the way it works is every even number is stable, and every odd number is experimental. So 2.5 and 2.3 and 2.1 were all sort of these experimental that,
穿过通道之类的。是的，我其实玩过这个。所以基本上，你知道，像大多数平台游戏一样，你跳跃并导航穿过世界，在这种情况下，它有点倒过来，你是让世界穿过你。是的，这很有趣。所以去看看吧，特别是如果你是一个游戏玩家，或者想支持一个好的事业。是的，绝对。所以我认为，嗯，Linux内核3.0发布了，这对像我们这样的极客来说真的很棒。它在2.x版本上停留了很长时间。是的，我的意思是，如果我没记错的话，它的工作方式是每个偶数版本是稳定的，每个奇数版本是实验性的。所以2.5、2.3和2.1都是这种实验性的，
as long as you were running, if you were running an operating system like Ubuntu or Gen 2 or something like that, you never got those versions. But all the even numbers, like 2.6, 2.4, were the ones that went out to production. And so to go to 3, a lot of people thought that it might even go to 2.6, 2.4 were the ones that went out to production. And so to go to 3, just, you know, a lot of people thought that it might even go to 2.10. So to go to 3 is pretty wild. Yes, I'm looking here at a little graph. It looks like 2.0 was released in 1996. Wow, that dates us, huh? We were in high school. We actually, we were using that version that makes us feel kind of old. Yeah, I wasn't in high school. We actually were using that version. That makes us feel kind of old.
只要你在运行，如果你运行的是像Ubuntu或Gentoo之类的操作系统，你就永远不会得到这些版本。但所有的偶数版本，比如2.6、2.4，都是进入生产环境的版本。所以要进入3，很多人认为它甚至可能会进入2.10。所以进入3真的很疯狂。是的，我在这里看一张小图表。看起来2.0是在1996年发布的。哇，这暴露了我们的年龄，对吧？我们当时还在上高中。我们实际上是在使用那个版本，这让我们感觉有点老了。是的，我当时没上高中。我们实际上是在使用那个版本。这让我们感觉有点老了。
Yeah, I wasn't in high school. But I'm a little bit younger than you. Now I feel old. It's okay. Anyways, but yeah, so I guess they said 3.0. I was looking a little bit into it. I don't run the bleeding edge Linux kernel by any means. But it looked like there was some updates to it,
是的，我当时没上高中。但我比你年轻一点。现在我感觉老了。没关系。无论如何，但是的，所以我猜他们说了3.0。我稍微研究了一下。我绝不会运行最前沿的Linux内核。但看起来有一些更新，
but they were more kind of relatively going to 3.0 which seems like a big deal um there was only a few minor updates and it just wanted to get to 3.0 they just you know too many too long had they been in the two point region and so they were ready to move on to 3.0 and they decided this is as good a time as any yeah that's cool i mean as the article mentions, there's LinuxCon. There's, you know, a bunch of different conventions. And, you know, being a Linux developer is a largely social experience because you think about it, you're writing drivers.
但它们更多是相对地进入3.0，这看起来是一件大事。嗯，只有几个小的更新，他们只是想进入3.0。他们只是，你知道，在2.x区域停留太久了，所以他们准备好进入3.0，他们决定现在是最好的时机。是的，这很酷。我的意思是，正如文章提到的，有LinuxCon。有各种各样的会议。而且，成为一名Linux开发者在很大程度上是一种社交体验，因为你想想，你在编写驱动程序。
And, you know, often, I mean, of course, there's algorithms involved and things like that. But a lot of the work, a lot of the code base is drivers for different hardware. To implement these drivers, you have to talk to a lot of people. It's kind of a social environment. As the 20th birthday approaches, bumping up to 3.0 is sort of a little cute gesture. Yeah, generate some buzz and get people excited. Yeah, definitely. yep so that's big
而且，你知道，通常，我的意思是，当然，涉及算法之类的东西。但很多工作，很多代码库是针对不同硬件的驱动程序。要实现这些驱动程序，你必须与很多人交谈。这是一种社交环境。随着20周年纪念日的临近，提升到3.0是一种可爱的小姿态。是的，制造一些轰动，让人们兴奋起来。是的，绝对。是的，所以这是大
news doesn't happen very often yeah yeah that's some great news but i think we're we have to sadly end on a more somber note yeah another thing that's been uh you know as long as i can remember since uh i don't know if i said this before but living in florida um the space shuttle has always been something that you know you can always hear the sonic booms when it comes back in to the atmosphere. You know, I've been out to a number of launches, which is there's just really nothing to compare. It's something you can't capture in video or words or describe. And sadly, shuttle programs now at an end. Yeah.
新闻，并不经常发生。是的，那是一些很棒的新闻，但我认为我们不得不悲伤地以一个更沉重的话题结束。是的，另一件事是，嗯，你知道，只要我能记得，自从，我不知道我之前是否说过，住在佛罗里达，航天飞机一直是可以听到的东西，当它回到大气层时，你可以听到音爆。你知道，我参加过很多次发射，真的没有什么可以比较的。这是你无法用视频或文字捕捉或描述的东西。可悲的是，航天飞机项目现在结束了。是的。
I believe they're going to continue doing unmanned space flight is that correct but not through nasa no no so so they are so um nasa is going to continue to do you know all the other stuff it's been doing and there is plans for more manned space flight they just don't have a manned space flight replacement now for the shuttle i see so we'll be using to go to the international space station and, I see. So we'll be using, to go to the International Space Station and to do any other sort, we'll be using rockets from other countries. So mainly the Soyuz capsule from Russia
我相信他们将继续进行无人航天飞行，这是正确的吗？但不是通过NASA。不，不，所以他们是，嗯，NASA将继续做它一直在做的所有其他事情，并且有更多载人航天的计划，他们只是现在没有载人航天的替代品来代替航天飞机。我明白了。所以我们将使用去国际空间站，我明白了。所以我们将使用，去国际空间站，并进行任何其他类型的，我们将使用来自其他国家的火箭。所以主要是俄罗斯的联盟号（Soyuz）太空舱
to send people into space. And then in about, the numbers constantly change, but in about four to five years, they plan to have something that we have that we can send people up. And there's a big push, though though for there to be more private involvement so private companies instead of, so NASA for those who don't live
把人送入太空。然后在大约，数字不断变化，但大约四到五年内，他们计划拥有我们可以把人送上去的东西。不过，人们非常推动私营部门的参与，所以私营公司而不是，所以NASA，对于那些不住在
in the United States, NASA is a government organization and so they're trying to get more private organizations that will send people to space and then NASA can basically just buy tickets on other like an airline right, NASA just wants to buy people to space and then nasa can basically just buy tickets on other on other like an airline right you know nasa just wants to buy tickets to space uh to send people hilarious i
美国的人来说，NASA是一个政府组织，所以他们正试图让更多的私营组织把人送入太空，然后NASA基本上可以买票，就像航空公司一样，对吧？NASA只是想买票把人送入太空。太搞笑了，我
wonder what do you know do you have any insight into what a private company would do like like would they just basically sell you know tickets to visit space and come back is that the idea so there's a number of uh companies doing this and this is a kind of a highly charged political thing so i'll try to stay non-political in this discussion but um yeah so various companies have different motives some have the idea of space tourism which is you know send people into sub-orbit or low orbit or to even you know there's the idea of having space hotels and sending people to that right and then the cheaper you can make it the more people on earth will have money to be able to do that and then then there's other people who say you know only big government sponsored contractors
想知道，你知道，你对私营公司会做什么有什么见解吗？比如，他们会基本上卖票去太空参观然后回来吗？这就是想法吗？所以有很多公司在做这个，这是一个高度敏感的政治问题，所以我会在这次讨论中尽量保持非政治性。但嗯，是的，各种公司有不同的动机。有些有太空旅游的想法，也就是，你知道，把人送入亚轨道或低轨道，甚至，你知道，有太空旅馆的想法，把人送到那里，对吧？然后你制造得越便宜，地球上就会有越多的人有钱能够做到这一点。然后还有其他人说，你知道，只有大型政府赞助的承包商
and the government themselves can send satellites and so there's a lot of people who would want to send satellites if they're cheaper or it would just be better for everybody if they were cheaper. So they're trying to be able to send satellites. Well, if you can send a big enough satellite, the satellite can just be a capsule that has humans in it. And so but then you add this all much more important to keep safety in mind and that kind of stuff. So, you know, but basically the humans in a capsule become the payload instead of a satellite and so there's some people who are taking that approach so basically being cargo ships with the one day being able to put humans there too nice that sounds cool so yeah but it uh you know it's
和政府自己可以发送卫星，所以有很多人想发送卫星，如果它们更便宜，或者如果它们更便宜，对每个人来说都会更好。所以他们正试图能够发送卫星。好吧，如果你能发送足够大的卫星，卫星就可以是一个载人的太空舱。所以，但随后你增加了这个，记住安全等等更重要。所以，你知道，但基本上太空舱里的人变成了有效载荷，而不是卫星。所以有些人正在采取这种方法，基本上是货船，有一天也能把人送上去。不错，听起来很酷。所以，是的，但它，你知道，它
kind of an interesting thing because we were the you know there was only a couple ways to get humans into space right now and so to see one of those methods go away, it's a little bit sad. Yeah. And I mean, you know, within, well, not within our generation, but, but, you know, there's plenty of people, you know, all the baby boomers who are around, you know, remember, you know, in their lifetimes, the Sputnik and the space fever and Carl Sagan, you know, people just really, you know, pushing the envelope on educating people about space and the universe and the cosmos. And yeah, to go from that to canceling the program is, yeah, it's a little sad. But, you know, now we have new technologies
是一件有趣的事情，因为我们是，你知道，现在只有几种方法可以把人送入太空，所以看到其中一种方法消失，有点悲伤。是的。我的意思是，你知道，在，嗯，不是在我们这一代，但，但，你知道，有很多人，你知道，所有的婴儿潮一代，你知道，记得，在他们的一生中，斯普特尼克（Sputnik）和太空热，卡尔·萨根（Carl Sagan），你知道，人们真的，你知道，在教育人们关于太空、宇宙和天体方面不断突破极限。是的，从那到取消项目，是的，有点悲伤。但是，你知道，现在我们有了新技术
that are sort of fueling our imagination. Yeah, and Mars rovers and, you know, seeing the footage of them driving around on a planet so far away is that is really exciting as well. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. And so I feel like I don't feel like we've lost the the fire of innovation. I just feel like it's being diverted to, you know, other things. And there's just something cool about watching all those sci-fi and imagining us being one step closer to being able to ride around on spaceships throughout our space yep but uh yeah yeah i think it's just that part of the geek and you kind of get sad yeah yeah definitely yeah i mean you know now that any aliens passing by aren't going to see our inter interstellar or interplanetary vehicles because they will just
正在推动我们的想象力。是的，还有火星探测器，你知道，看到它们在遥远的星球上行驶的镜头，这也非常令人兴奋。是的。是的，绝对。所以我感觉，我不觉得我们失去了创新的火焰。我只是觉得它被转移到了，你知道，其他事情上。而且看着所有那些科幻小说，想象我们离能够乘坐宇宙飞船在太空中航行更近了一步，这真的很酷。是的，但，是的，是的，我想这只是极客的那一部分，你有点难过。是的，是的，绝对。我的意思是，你知道，现在任何经过的外星人都不会看到我们的星际或行星际交通工具，因为他们只会
not the manned ones so yeah all right yeah time for oh sorry yeah oh no i was gonna say it's time for the tool of the bi-week all right you're up first man all right uh my tool the bi-week is free mind and uh i've actually been using this a lot lately because i've had to sort of, I've been doing sort of, not really a lot of design, but I guess I've been trying to really educate myself on a lot of different technologies lately. And this really sort of helps to let you sort of jot down a bunch of ideas really quickly. Basically, what FreeMind is, it's a tool for creating a tree of of phrases and uh actually you can even hold you know rich text and paragraphs what have you but you know you have a root node which might
不是载人的。所以，是的，好吧，是时候，哦，抱歉，是的，哦不，我本来想说，是时候进行双周工具（tool of the bi-week）了。好吧，你先来，伙计。好的，我的双周工具是FreeMind，我最近一直在用这个，因为我不得不，你知道，我一直在做，不是很多设计，但我猜我一直在努力在最近学习很多不同的技术。这真的有助于让你快速记下很多想法。基本上，FreeMind是什么，它是一个用于创建短语树的工具，实际上你甚至可以保存富文本和段落等等，但你知道，你有一个根节点，它可能是
be let's say the root node is uh you know html and then just there might be different categories of html that you want to learn like you want to. Like you want to study different like divs and how to write divs. You want to study tables, like different things. So you can have sort of this tree structure with like a root node and then children. And this thing automatically draws the tree and helps to reposition the tree. Like if one of the areas of the tree gets very large, it'll move all the nodes around. But it's a way to just quickly jot down a bunch of ideas in a medium that allows you to sort of make connections and allows you to think critically. So it's like making an outline but more freeform.
让我们说根节点是HTML，然后可能有一些你想学习的HTML的不同类别，比如你想。比如你想学习不同的div以及如何编写div。你想学习表格，不同的东西。所以你可以有这种树状结构，有一个根节点和子节点。这个东西会自动绘制树并帮助重新定位树。比如如果树的一个区域变得非常大，它会移动所有的节点。但它是一种在允许你建立联系并允许你批判性思考的媒介中快速记下很多想法的方法。所以它就像制作大纲，但更自由。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. And it's totally cross-platform and open source. So I believe it's written in Java. So you can use it on any any os and you can even you know take your mind map uh from one computer to another can you like export it to like a pdf or something if you want to be able to send it to somebody else or yep yeah it actually lets you export it to a number of different formats one is html ironically which we'll talk about later um but it'll let you you know export it to a website export it to pdf But it'll let you export it to a website, export it to PDF.
是的，是的，完全正确。而且它是完全跨平台和开源的。所以我相信它是用Java编写的。所以你可以在任何操作系统上使用它，你甚至可以，你知道，把你的思维导图从一台电脑带到另一台电脑。你可以把它导出为PDF之类的吗，如果你想把它发给别人？是的，它实际上允许你把它导出为许多不同的格式，其中一个是HTML，讽刺的是，我们稍后会谈到它，但它会让你，你知道，导出到网站，导出到PDF。
It'll let you do many different image formats. And it's really slick. It'll even import. If you have like an XML file, it can import that and make a mind map out of it, which can be useful. So my tool is, I think most people kind of know about this. And I'm on a streak. You're always on the open source stuff. And I kind of haven't been doing open source stuff. I'm probably garnering a lot of glares from people in our audience, but that's okay.
它会让你做许多不同的图像格式。而且它真的很顺滑。它甚至可以导入。如果你有像XML文件这样的东西，它可以导入它并从中制作思维导图，这可能很有用。所以我的工具是，我想大多数人都知道这个。而且我一直在坚持。你总是用开源的东西。而我一直没怎么用开源的东西。我可能从我们的观众那里得到了很多瞪眼，但没关系。
Yeah, so this week I chose my tool as Picasa, which is a photo management and, you know, kind of editing software from Google. And I've been taking a lot of photos recently and is it you don't realize now how many pictures you really take between having them on mobile phones and a point and shoot and i have a nice slr camera and you go on vacation you come back with just you know literally hundreds of photos and having them like with weird names and sometimes they get off on dates or something and it just it can be really a mess to track them and sort them and then there's all this you know cleanup you need to do because inevitably you can tweak the picture some some little way and make it
是的，所以这周我选择的工具是Picasa，它是来自谷歌的照片管理和，你知道，某种编辑软件。我最近拍了很多照片，你现在没有意识到在手机、傻瓜相机和我有的一台不错的单反相机之间，你真的拍了多少照片。你去度假，回来时只有，你知道，字面上的数百张照片，而且它们的名字很奇怪，有时日期会出错，跟踪和分类它们真的会是一团糟。然后还有所有这些，你知道，你需要做的清理工作，因为不可避免地你可以以某种方式微调图片，让它
better um and so picasa has been really good to be able to handle that i have tried a couple of open source photo management tools and i just never made it through the learning curve of getting used to them yeah so does Picasa use the cloud or is it all on your computer so it has support for both um I mainly use it just because that's I don't have that many photos and I don't really share them with people because I've it kind of to me ends up I'm not a great photographer so I feel like it's watching somebody's boring vacation video. And so I don't typically feel compelled to share my pictures with people. But yeah, they have, so mine is just used on my local computer, but they have the ability to store it, Picasa Online and Picasa Web Albums.
更好。嗯，所以Picasa在处理这个问题上真的很棒。我尝试过几个开源的照片管理工具，但我从来没有克服学习曲线去习惯它们。是的，那么Picasa使用云端还是都在你的电脑上？它对两者都有支持。嗯，我主要使用它只是因为，我没有那么多照片，而且我真的不和别人分享它们，因为对我来说，我不是一个伟大的摄影师，所以我感觉这就像在看别人的无聊度假视频。所以我通常不会觉得有必要和别人分享我的照片。但是的，他们有，所以我的只是在我的本地电脑上使用，但他们有能力存储它，Picasa Online和Picasa Web Albums。
Which is integrated in the new Google+, which you were talking about last time. Which I guess now we we are both both on there and we have a couple we have about 12 people following us on programming throwdown on google plus so we should give a shout out for that um but uh picasso web albums and integrate tightly with that so you could post from picasso the computer application and be able to use that in one of your google plus posts yeah definitely we should mention that we uh we are on google plus and uh if you do add and be able to use that in one of your Google Plus posts. Yeah, definitely. We should mention that we are on Google Plus. And if you do add Programming Throwdown, make sure to add us too
它集成在新的Google+中，你上次谈到了。我想现在我们俩都在上面，我们在Google Plus上的Programming Throwdown有大约12个人关注，所以我们应该为此大喊一声。但嗯，Picasa Web Albums和它紧密集成，所以你可以从Picasa电脑应用程序发布，并能够在你的Google Plus帖子中使用它。是的，绝对，我们应该提到我们，我们是在Google Plus上。如果你添加并能够在你的Google Plus帖子中使用它。是的，绝对。我们应该提到我们是在Google Plus上。如果你添加了Programming Throwdown，一定要也添加我们，
because sometimes we'll post geeky stuff from our personal accounts that might be interesting. But we will use the Programming Throwdown account to post when there are new episodes and things like that. So it's definitely very useful. Yeah, I'd be interested in hearing if people want us to post kind of news stories as we see them to Programming Throwdown or whether they just like that to be podcast announcements. Yeah, definitely.
因为有时我们会从我们的个人账户发布可能很有趣的极客内容。但我们会使用Programming Throwdown账户来发布新剧集之类的内容。所以它绝对非常有用。是的，如果人们希望我们向Programming Throwdown发布新闻故事，或者他们只是喜欢它是播客公告，我会很感兴趣。是的，绝对。
So shoot us some feedback on Plus and let us know, sort of kind of help dictate the flow of information across that. Yeah, because I could see that as being useful. You know, you'll have these people who say news and that'd be kind of cool to hear it from there. But other people might go, no, no, no, I don't really want more noise. Yeah, that's right. So yeah, let us know. About the Picasa, I mean, my concern is like, so I have a bunch of photos and I have a gallery software that I run on my computer. My concern is like if there was to be a fire in my apartment and my computer and everything and it burned to the ground, I'd lose all of my memories.
所以给我们一些关于Plus的反馈，让我们知道，某种程度上帮助决定信息流。是的，因为我觉得这很有用。你知道，你会让这些人说新闻，从那里听到会很酷。但其他人可能会说，不，不，不，我真的不想要更多的噪音。是的，没错。所以，是的，让我们知道。关于Picasa，我的意思是，我的担心是，我有许多照片，我有一个我在电脑上运行的画廊软件。我的担心是，如果我的公寓发生火灾，我的电脑和所有东西都烧毁了，我会失去我所有的记忆。
That sounds really sad and drastic. I know. It's devastating. Is there a way in Picasso where you can say, look, I want to put these on the cloud, but I don't really want to share them or anything. I just want to keep them there just in case. Yeah, yeah. I mean, you can keep them private. And for a backup purpose, that's good.
这听起来真的很悲伤和剧烈。我知道。这是毁灭性的。在Picasa里有没有办法说，看，我想把这些放在云端，但我真的不想分享它们或任何东西。我只是想以防万一保留它们。是的，是的。我的意思是，你可以保持私密。为了备份目的，这很好。
And I believe you actually, there's a, you know, they give you so much space for free. And then if you want more space, you know, there's a fee. And I don't think the fee is actually very much. But that's their arrangement. But I actually use separate separate which i guess we should talk about at some point backup strategy but that is important to make sure you're backed up and a lot of times people back up to external hard drives and that's good but if something happens to your house flood you're moving whatever and they lose the hard drive then what um yeah so that's kind of better than nothing but not still the greatest so um i actually run some other software that i use to back up more than just my pictures but kind of my
而且我相信你实际上，有一个，你知道，他们免费给你很多空间。然后如果你想要更多空间，你知道，有一个费用。而且我不认为费用其实很高。但那是他们的安排。但我实际上使用单独的，单独的，我想我们应该在某个时候谈谈备份策略，但确保你备份很重要。很多时候人们备份到外部硬盘，这很好，但如果你的房子发生洪水，你搬家，无论什么，他们丢失了硬盘，那怎么办？嗯，是的，所以这比什么都没有要好，但仍然不是最好的。所以，嗯，我实际上运行了一些其他软件，我用它来备份不仅仅是我的照片，还有我的
my music and other stuff to the cloud really yeah yeah we'll definitely we should definitely talk about that next episode or something yeah and there's there's a number of different ways to do that all of them work fairly well. Cool. All right, so we're talking about programming languages, HTML, and CSS on this show. And the hope is this is going to be a two-parter. We're going to start off by talking about HTML and CSS, which is mainly for making static web pages.
音乐和其他东西到云端。真的吗？是的，是的，我们绝对应该在下一期节目中谈谈这个。是的，有许多不同的方法可以做到这一点，所有这些方法都相当有效。酷。好吧，所以我们在节目中谈论编程语言、HTML和CSS。希望这是一个两部分的内容。我们将从谈论HTML和CSS开始，这主要是为了制作静态网页。
And then we'll go on and talk about JavaScriptavascript in the next episode for making you know dynamic web content and uh yeah the goal is at the end of these two parts for people to really have a good understanding you know when they go to a web page especially you know nowadays with modern websites like you know gmail for example where it's constantly you know checking for new emails you know what's actually happening under the scenes yeah definitely i mean some people kind of you know i was telling some people that uh you know we were going to be covering html and css and then they were like oh it's not really a programming language. But, I mean, it is really so vital to a lot of what's being done today. And it kind of serves, if not a programming languages by some definition,
然后我们将继续谈论下一期节目中的JavaScript，用于制作，你知道，动态网页内容。嗯，是的，目标是在这两部分结束时，人们真正对当你访问一个网页时，特别是，你知道，现在有了现代网站，比如，你知道，Gmail，它不断地，你知道，检查新邮件，你知道，幕后到底发生了什么，有一个很好的理解。是的，绝对。我的意思是，有些人，你知道，我告诉一些人，嗯，你知道，我们将要涵盖HTML和CSS，然后他们说，哦，那不是真正的编程语言。但是，我的意思是，它对于今天正在做的事情确实非常重要。而且它有点服务，如果不是某种定义上的编程语言，
I mean, it does have very close analogies and similarities to programming languages. And, I mean, I don't know if HTML, it doesn't have loops and stuff like that, like you might associate with a normal programming language, but it is something you can write. It's something that's in a way executed by the browser, which we'll talk about in a second. And I mean, all of us use the web. I mean, that's probably how you found this podcast even. So it really is important to know the technologies that underlie that. Yeah, I feel like, you know, in many cases people would argue that a programming language is one that lets you manipulate things.
我的意思是，它确实与编程语言有非常接近的类比和相似之处。而且，我的意思是，我不知道HTML是否，它没有循环之类的东西，就像你可能与普通编程语言联系在一起的那样，但它是你可以编写的东西。它是浏览器以某种方式执行的东西，我们稍后会谈到。而且我的意思是，我们所有人都使用网络。我的意思是，这可能就是你找到这个播客的方式。所以了解其背后的技术确实很重要。是的，我觉得，你知道，在许多情况下，人们会争辩说编程语言是一种让你操纵东西的语言。
And so, you know, something like PHP or something which we'll talk about later would be a programming language that lets you create HTML, and HTML is sort of the output of a programming language. But, you know, remember that, and we'll talk about this more later, but basically HTML is read by the web browser and processed. And there's many instructions there, like go grab this image or move this table over there. So in many ways, there's a lot of computation going on.
所以，你知道，像PHP之类的东西，我们稍后会谈到，将是一种让你创建HTML的编程语言，而HTML是某种编程语言的输出。但是，你知道，记住，我们稍后会更多地谈论这一点，但基本上HTML是由网络浏览器读取和处理的。那里有很多指令，比如去抓取这个图像或把这个表格移到那里。所以从很多方面来看，有很多计算正在进行。
I feel like that can be underestimated. Yeah, and it is such a fundamental part of you know like you like you indicated output of PHP there's you know all sorts of we're talking about second web frameworks that output HTML and CSS so yeah you can it's almost an intermediate language it's the output of a language that gets run on a browser yep so so fuck oh go no i was just gonna say so i mean it is a markup language so what where does that come what's a markup language yeah so this is actually an old term from the printing press days where they would
我觉得这可能被低估了。是的，它是你，你知道，像你指出的PHP的输出的一个如此基础的部分，有，你知道，各种各样的，我们正在谈论输出HTML和CSS的第二网络框架。所以，是的，你可以，它几乎是一种中间语言，它是运行在浏览器上的语言的输出。是的，所以，所以，去，不，我只是想说，所以，我的意思是，它是一种标记语言，那么它来自哪里，什么是标记语言？是的，所以这实际上是印刷机时代的旧术语，他们会
actually use you know position rubber stamps so they would have they would have i think they were metal but yes go ahead oh really oh yeah i guess that makes more sense um but they would have they would have i think they were metal but yes go ahead oh really oh yeah i guess that makes more sense um but they would basically get you know they would want these sort of blue collar laborers to go and position these stamps uh every day for the printing press to run you know newspapers or magazines etc and so they created this language to say, you know, to give a very generic way of laying things down on the paper. And so when the HTTP protocol was invented very early on, you know, it was clear that they wanted to use it to disseminate information. So they decided that, you know, there's already this markup language in place for newspapers and books. So they might as well sort of leverage some of this and create a hypertext,
实际上使用，你知道，定位橡皮图章，所以他们会有，我想它们应该是金属做的，但是是的，请继续，哦真的吗，哦是的，我想这更有道理，嗯，但他们基本上会，你知道，他们会想要这些蓝领工人们去每天定位这些图章，以便印刷机运行，你知道，报纸或杂志等等，所以他们创造了这种语言来说，你知道，提供一种非常通用的方式将东西放在纸上。因此，当 HTTP 协议在很早的时候被发明出来时，你知道，很明显他们想用它来传播信息。所以他们决定，你知道，已经有这种用于报纸和书籍的标记语言了。所以他们不妨利用其中的一些并创建一个超文本，
a markup language that can be used over the Internet. And so that is what HTML is, hypertext markup language. Nice, nice. So we talked a little bit there about the HTTP protocol and the web. So it might be good if we walk through kind of the process. This isn't specific to HTML, but it gives us the context for where HTML fits in this pipeline, as it were, of what happens when you go to your web browser and you type in a site and how does HTML get there and get rendered and all that part yeah yeah that's
一种可以在互联网上使用的标记语言。这就是 HTML，超文本标记语言。不错，不错。所以我们刚才谈到了一点关于 HTTP 协议和网络的内容。所以如果我们能走一遍这个过程可能会很好。这并不是 HTML 特有的，但它为我们提供了 HTML 在这个管道中处于什么位置的背景，也就是当你进入你的网络浏览器并输入一个网站时会发生什么，以及 HTML 是如何到达那里并被渲染的，所有这些部分，是的，是的，那是
that's really important so let's i guess let's start here you go to any website uh you know aol.com right and you would enter and it and the first thing it does is it you know turns aol.com into an ip address using something called dns and we will kind of leave that for another time it has this number address on the internet and it actually opens up a TCP connection TCP stands for transport control
那真的很重要，所以让我们，我想让我们从这里开始，你进入任何网站，你知道，aol.com，对吧，你会输入它，它做的第一件事就是，你知道，使用一种叫做 DNS 的东西把 aol.com 变成一个 IP 地址，我们暂时先不谈这个，它在互联网上有这个数字地址，它实际上打开了一个 TCP 连接，TCP 代表传输控制
protocol and opens a TCP session and then makes a HTTP request on that session. So the request will contain different things like a little header saying, you know, who's making the request, some information about them. It'll contain some parameters and it'll contain a cookie. So we'll talk about these. Basically, let's say you visit a website and you'll go and make a request with no parameters, like AOL.com. No parameters, I just want to see what AOL has to give me.
协议，并打开一个 TCP 会话，然后在该会话上发出一个 HTTP 请求。所以请求将包含不同的东西，比如一个小标题，说明，你知道，是谁发出的请求，关于他们的一些信息。它将包含一些参数，并且它将包含一个 cookie。所以我们会谈论这些。基本上，假设你访问一个网站，你会去发出一个没有参数的请求，比如 AOL.com。没有参数，我只是想看看 AOL 有什么可以给我的。
The server will receive your request. Now, the request is going to go through many layers. The first layer it'll hit on the server side when they've got your request is called a layer of filters. So they might have filters that say is this person logged into AOL if they're not then send them to the login page you know is this person coming from another country if they are then redirect them to AOL dot de or AOL dot CN for China then it will after it passes through all these filters, it goes to what's
服务器将收到你的请求。现在，请求将经过许多层。当他们收到你的请求时，它在服务器端命中的第一层被称为过滤器层。所以他们可能有过滤器，说这个人是否登录了 AOL，如果他们没有，那么就把他们送到登录页面，你知道，这个人是否来自另一个国家，如果是，那么把他们重定向到 AOL.de 或 AOL.CN（针对中国），然后它在通过所有这些过滤器后，它会进入所谓的
called a servlet, which is a piece of code on the server dedicated to handling a specific client request. So in this case, it'd probably be a front page servlet for AOL. And you would go on there and it would serve you, you know, the servlet would return the front page contents. Maybe there's some news articles, et cetera. And it would return this as HTML. And when it returned it, it would return, it would give you a response. And the response contains the, you know, the packet, the payload, which is, in this case, you know, an HTML, you know, a block of HTML, and it will contain some header information.
Servlet，这是服务器上专门用于处理特定客户端请求的一段代码。所以在这个例子中，它可能是 AOL 的首页 Servlet。你会去那里，它会为你服务，你知道，Servlet 会返回首页内容。也许有一些新闻文章等等。它会以 HTML 的形式返回这个。当它返回它时，它会返回，它会给你一个响应。响应包含，你知道，数据包，有效载荷，在这个例子中，你知道，一个 HTML，你知道，一个 HTML 块，并且它将包含一些头部信息。
So it will tell you the multi-purpose internet mail extensions or MIME type. So in this case the MIME type would be HTML because they're giving you an HTML page. They could also be giving you other things which you know i'll talk about in a second so the header information will also contain a cookie and the cookie is a way for you and the website to pass information back and forth and so we'll talk about that also a little bit later there's actually a lot that goes on much more than you would think when you hit a website so that's because the http is stateless so it doesn't maintain an inherent state about the connection every time you go to a website and say hey i want your web page without the cookie part it would just give you the default web page and would know nothing else right because it doesn't keep like oh you came back you were just here a second ago
所以它会告诉你多用途互联网邮件扩展或 MIME 类型。所以在这个例子中，MIME 类型将是 HTML，因为他们给你的是一个 HTML 页面。他们也可能给你其他东西，你知道，我一会儿会谈到，所以头部信息也将包含一个 cookie，而 cookie 是你和网站来回传递信息的一种方式，所以我们稍后也会谈论这个，实际上当你点击一个网站时，发生的事情比你想象的要多得多，这是因为 HTTP 是无状态的，所以它不会在每次你访问一个网站并说嘿，我想要你的网页时，在没有 cookie 部分的情况下维护关于连接的固有状态，它只会给你默认的网页，并且不知道其他任何事情，对吧，因为它不会保持像哦，你回来了，你刚才就在这里
why here's what you were doing last time um And so all that is pushed onto the client side, which is the browser versus the server, which is the part hosting the code. And so the client has to maintain any state that's necessary and change how it interacts with the server so the server knows who it is. Yeah, exactly. So like two ways to do state.
为什么，这是你上次在做的事情，嗯，所以所有这些都被推到了客户端，也就是浏览器，而不是服务器，也就是托管代码的部分。因此，客户端必须维护任何必要的状态，并改变它与服务器交互的方式，以便服务器知道它是谁。是的，完全正确。所以就像有两种方式来处理状态。
One would be, let's say you're looking at the news now on AOL News or something. You can pass in what's called a parameter to the website. So you go to AOL, and it shows you the first news article, and you want to see the second one. So you click the little arrow that says go to the second news article. What your browser can do is it can go to aol.com question mark 2. And so whenever you see a question mark at the end of a URL, at the end of an address, anything after the question mark is a set of parameters. So you could say, question mark page equals two. And when that request gets to the server, the server will see you want to go to AOL.com,
一种是，假设你现在正在 AOL 新闻或其他什么地方看新闻。你可以向网站传递所谓的参数。所以你进入 AOL，它向你展示第一篇新闻文章，而你想看第二篇。所以你点击那个写着去第二篇新闻文章的小箭头。你的浏览器可以做的是它可以去 aol.com 问号 2。所以每当你看到 URL 末尾、地址末尾有一个问号时，问号后面的任何东西都是一组参数。所以你可以说，问号 page 等于 2。当那个请求到达服务器时，服务器会看到你想去 AOL.com，
but it will also see this page variable is set to two. And the servlet might intercept that and say, oh, this person wants the second news article and return that. There's another way. There's actually two more ways to send information to the server. The second is through what's called a post. So whenever you have the question mark and the page equal to at the end of the URL, that's called a get request.
但它也会看到这个 page 变量被设置为 2。而 Servlet 可能会拦截它并说，哦，这个人想要第二篇新闻文章并返回它。还有另一种方式。实际上还有两种向服务器发送信息的方式。第二种是通过所谓的 post。所以每当你在 URL 末尾有问号和 page 等于 2 时，那被称为 get 请求。
There's also a post request, which is, I guess you could say a little bit more private. What it does is it does effectively the same thing as the get request. It would send page equal to over to the server, but it does it behind the scenes, so it doesn't show up in the URL. And so this is important. Let's say you wanted to— That's like where forms, right? It's like if you fill out something on a form and you push submit.
还有一个 post 请求，我想你可以说它稍微私密一点。它所做的是它实际上做了和 get 请求一样的事情。它会把 page 等于 2 发送到服务器，但它是在幕后做的，所以它不会出现在 URL 中。所以这很重要。假设你想——那就像表单所在的地方，对吧？就像如果你在表单上填写了一些东西并点击提交。
In theory, they could use it there. Exactly. Let's say you have a form where you're supposed to put in your first, last name, and your social. And you hit submit. Well, you don't want it to change the URL to question mark Patrick social equals 555 whatever, right? What? Don't share that? How did you find that out?
理论上，他们可以在那里使用它。完全正确。假设你有一个表单，你应该在其中输入你的名字、姓氏和你的社会保障号。然后你点击提交。好吧，你不想让它把 URL 变成问号 Patrick social 等于 555 什么的，对吧？什么？不要分享那个？你是怎么发现的？
Because you don't want your buddy behind you looking at out because you don't want like your buddy behind you looking at the url and knowing your social right although or even just you know you leave the computer all of the urls you visit are in your history you don't want your social in your history your social security number so um so post gives you a little bit more security there but by far the best security comes from cookies and what cookies are are is basically an object that gets passed from you to the server and then also passed back from the server to you so you know the posts and the guts are one way but the cookies are two way and so cookies are a way for you to do a bunch of really interesting encryption things between yourself, the client, and the server.
因为你不想让你身后的伙伴看着，因为你不想让你身后的伙伴看着 URL 并知道你的社会保障号，对吧，虽然或者甚至只是，你知道，你离开电脑，你访问的所有 URL 都在你的历史记录中，你不想让你的社会保障号在你的历史记录中，你的社会保障号码，所以嗯，所以 post 在那里给了你一点更多的安全性，但到目前为止，最好的安全性来自 cookie，而 cookie 是什么，基本上是一个从你传递到服务器，然后也从服务器传回给你的对象，所以你知道，post 和 get 是一条路，但 cookie 是双向的，所以 cookie 是你和你之间进行很多非常有趣的加密事情的一种方式，客户端和服务器。
So for example, you don't want to just pass your social security number like PatrickSocial equals this across the internet. So what you might do is you might pass a cookie saying, hey, here's a key. And then the server might pass back another cookie or a third party might pass you another cookie across the internet and say, hey, here's some other key. And using these different keys, you can encrypt your password and then pass that encrypted password as another cookie.
所以例如，你不想只是像 PatrickSocial 等于这个这样在互联网上传递你的社会保障号码。所以你可能会做的是你可能会传递一个 cookie 说，嘿，这是一个密钥。然后服务器可能会传回另一个 cookie，或者第三方可能会在互联网上给你传递另一个 cookie 并说，嘿，这是另一个密钥。并且使用这些不同的密钥，你可以加密你的密码，然后把那个加密的密码作为另一个 cookie 传递。
So cookies allow you to do a little bit more fancy message passing back and forth. But yeah, basically... fancy uh uh you know message passing back and forth um but yeah basically so you ultimately get this this html description in this mime and that we talked about that it's uh that it's a markup so it shows here by whatever means you know that's gone on behind the scenes but it finally arrives at your browser and then your browser has to do something with it so it goes through and finds tags right those are the if you ever look at it those are the things in the angle brackets and and says hey this is markup this is telling me to stick this thing here or you know this thing over there and so then it goes through and parses that information, reads it, and decides what to do with it.
所以 cookie 允许你做更多花哨的消息来回传递。但是是的，基本上……花哨的嗯嗯你知道消息来回传递嗯但是的基本上所以你最终得到了这个 HTML 描述在这个 MIME 中，我们谈到了它是一个标记，所以它在这里显示，无论通过什么方式，你知道，在幕后发生了什么，但它最终到达了你的浏览器，然后你的浏览器必须用它做点什么，所以它会遍历并找到标签，对吧，如果你曾经看过它，那些是尖括号里的东西，并且说嘿，这是标记，这是在告诉我把这个东西放在这里，或者你知道，把那个东西放在那里，所以然后它会遍历并解析该信息，读取它，并决定用它做什么。
And then it may also contain, hey, you need to go grab this other thing. Like we'll talk about in a second, but go grab this CSS, this cascading style sheet from over here, or go grab this image at this URL and then render it and stick it here. And so once it has that,
然后它也可能包含，嘿，你需要去获取这个其他东西。就像我们一会儿会谈到的，但去获取这个 CSS，这个层叠样式表，从这里，或者去获取这个 URL 处的这个图像，然后渲染它并把它放在这里。所以一旦它有了那个，
your browser gets the HTML, but then it has to go back to the server possibly and get more information. It might have to make other requests to get images, to get other things that might be there. Exactly. Yeah, so when the server returns that response, it will have that MIME that we talked about. So you might grab the HTML, and the HTML might say, hey, you need a bunch of images. And you might go to the server and say, hey, I need to get this resource. And I'm pretty sure it's an image. So you could tell the server, hey, I want this resource in the MIME.
你的浏览器得到了 HTML，但然后它可能必须回到服务器并获取更多信息。它可能必须发出其他请求来获取图像，获取可能在那里的其他东西。完全正确。是的，所以当服务器返回那个响应时，它会有我们谈到的那个 MIME。所以你可能会获取 HTML，而 HTML 可能会说，嘿，你需要一堆图像。你可能会去服务器说，嘿，我需要获取这个资源。而且我很确定它是一个图像。所以你可以告诉服务器，嘿，我想要这个 MIME 中的资源。
I think it's an image. And the server will return back and say, yes, the MIME, it's an image. It's a PNG image, or it's a JPEG. And here's the payload. In this case, it's not HTML, but it's just a chunk of data that represents a JPEG image or a cascading style sheet or many other things. Yeah, so that describes kind of where to stick the data on the page, how to locate it in ways. But you could make the HTML describe and only have an html and have a static you know web page with just text and colors and and you know that kind of stuff but as you try
我想它是一个图像。服务器会返回并说，是的，MIME，它是一个图像。它是一个 PNG 图像，或者它是一个 JPEG。这是有效载荷。在这个例子中，它不是 HTML，但它只是一块代表 JPEG 图像或层叠样式表或许多其他东西的数据。是的，所以这描述了某种把数据放在页面上的位置，定位它的方式。但你可以让 HTML 描述并只拥有一个 HTML，并拥有一个只有文本和颜色以及你知道那种东西的静态网页，但当你尝试
to do more and more it could get really complicated very intricate and um you know kind of have all these layers you're trying to do to get something exactly where you want on the page in a certain color with a certain look and feel and texture. But then when you want to make news page two, then you've got to recreate all that HTML code. And so cascading style sheets are a way to take away the data, the text, the paragraphs, the images, as it were, that the HTML represent, and the way those get rendered, kind of maybe where they go on the page, or the background color, or if you have like
做越来越多的时候，它可能会变得非常复杂，非常错综复杂，而且嗯你知道，你试图做所有这些层来把东西准确地放在你想要的位置，以某种颜色，具有某种外观和感觉和纹理。但当你想要制作新闻页面 2 时，你就必须重新创建所有的 HTML 代码。所以层叠样式表是一种拿走数据、文本、段落、图像（也就是 HTML 所代表的东西）以及它们被渲染的方式、某种程度上它们在页面上的位置，或者背景颜色，或者如果你有像
curvy edges on your tables or whatever, and put that in a separate document that separates how what the data is from how it gets presented or displayed. Yeah, exactly. I mean, let's say you had 100 web pages, 100 HTML pages that you were serving to people, and you wanted to change the font on all 100 of them. Well, that would be brutal because you'd have to change it on all of them. You'd have to make sure it looked right, and you'd have to change it on all of them, you'd have to make sure it looked right and you'd have to push it out, push 100 files out to the server so that they could be read by users.
表格上的弯曲边缘之类的东西，并把它放在一个单独的文档中，将数据是什么与它如何被呈现或显示分离开来。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，假设你有 100 个网页，100 个你正在为人们服务的 HTML 页面，而你想改变所有 100 个页面上的字体。好吧，那将是残酷的，因为你必须在所有页面上改变它。你必须确保它看起来正确，并且你必须在所有页面上改变它，你必须确保它看起来正确，并且你必须把它推出去，把 100 个文件推到服务器上，以便用户可以阅读它们。
If you have a CSS, a cascading style sheet, you can just make the change once in that style sheet and all the HTML files will just say, hey, use this style sheet over here and you know any any tat any text you know the fonts gonna be whatever this style sheet you know says it is yes they all reference the same style this Wow the same style sheet too many s's in a row the other thing so so the cascading part so the style sheet makes sense and and then the cascading comes in because you can get what what amounts to inheritance between the style sheet so like you know a master definition of some you know high level things for your site but then maybe you're in the forum section of your site so you could have a separate css that's for the forum
如果你有一个 CSS，一个层叠样式表，你可以在那个样式表中只做一次更改，所有的 HTML 文件都会说，嘿，使用这里的这个样式表，并且你知道任何任何标签任何文本你知道字体将是这个样式表你知道它所说的任何东西，是的，它们都引用相同的样式，这哇，相同的样式表，连续太多的 s，另一件事，所以所以层叠部分，所以样式表有意义，然后层叠进来是因为你可以得到相当于样式表之间的继承，所以就像你知道，为你网站的一些你知道高级东西的母定义，但然后也许你在你网站的论坛部分，所以你可以有一个单独的 CSS，是为论坛
section of the site which gives more specifics details that are only used there that aren't used somewhere else right like as patrick mentioned there's html is made up of a bunch of tags like you might have a tag that says here's an image you might have a tag that says here's a paragraph another tag might say here's a table or here's a heading and each tag has two things it can have up to two things it can have a style and it can have an id and they're both strings so you can have a table and the style is dark and the id is uh you know news table so you can only have the id is meant to be unique so if if one table is called news table the other one has to be called something else like like footer table or something yeah news table too but you could have 10 things all with the style
网站的部分，它提供了更多只在那里使用而不在其他地方使用的具体细节，对吧，就像 Patrick 提到的，HTML 是由一堆标签组成的，就像你可能有一个标签说这是一个图像，你可能有一个标签说这是一个段落，另一个标签可能说这是一个表格或这是一个标题，每个标签有两件事，它可以有最多两件事，它可以有一个样式，它可以有一个 ID，它们都是字符串，所以你可以有一个表格，样式是深色的，ID 是嗯你知道新闻表格，所以你只能有 ID 旨在是唯一的，所以如果一个表格被称为新闻表格，另一个必须被称为其他东西，比如像页脚表格之类的，是的，新闻表格 2，但你可以有 10 个东西，都带有样式
you know dark right and so where the cascading comes into play is you can say i want my font like in general i want my font to be helvetica but if my style is dark i want my font to be Helvetica. But if my style is dark, I want my font to be Arial Black. And if my style is dark and my ID is news, then I want my font to be Arial Black and bolded. So that's where the cascading comes into effect. It'll try and pick the most specific style. So it'll try and find a style for your specific ID. But if one doesn't exist, it'll take a step back and try and find a style for your specific id but if one doesn't exist it'll take a step back and try and find a style for your style uh tag attribute and if it
你知道深色，对吧，所以层叠发挥作用的地方是你可以说我想要我的字体，就像通常我想要我的字体是 Helvetica，但如果我的样式是深色，我想要我的字体是 Helvetica。但如果我的样式是深色，我想要我的字体是 Arial Black。如果我的样式是深色，我的 ID 是新闻，那么我想要我的字体是 Arial Black 并加粗。这就是层叠生效的地方。它会尝试选择最具体的样式。所以它会尝试为你的特定 ID 找到一个样式。但如果一个不存在，它会退后一步，尝试为你的特定 ID 找到一个样式，但如果一个不存在，它会退后一步，尝试为你的样式标签属性找到一个样式，如果它
doesn't find that it'll take another step back and say okay what's just the default font for all paragraphs and it'll use that if if it doesn't have anything there the web browser has its own default style sheet that it applies yeah and and that helps like you know like jason was indicating you know if you've got to put that file in one place then you have all these specifics laid out and you can have multiple style sheets and you only have to go change those you don't have to go change every single web page that you have which may be many, many, many web pages. Or in the case of if it's generated from a web framework, then you just have to worry about rendering the data and the CSS handles the style. And then you don't have to go and make sure your code knows how to output the formatting as much.
没有找到那个，它会再退后一步说，好吧，所有段落的默认字体是什么，如果它在那里没有任何东西，它就会使用那个，网络浏览器有它自己的默认样式表，它会应用，是的，这有帮助，就像你知道，就像 Jason 指出的，你知道，如果你必须把那个文件放在一个地方，那么你就有了所有这些具体的布局，你可以有多个样式表，你只需要去改变那些，你不必去改变你拥有的每一个网页，这可能是很多很多很多网页。或者在它是从 Web 框架生成的情况下，那么你只需要担心渲染数据，而 CSS 处理样式。然后你不必去确保你的代码知道如何输出格式化那么多。
Yeah. to output the formatting as much right yeah yeah i mean imagine an environment where you have a couple of web pages that are static and they're just dot html files but you also have some pages that are generated um you know based on certain content i mean maybe you're scanning the weather and you're giving someone a map but the map's generated based on the weather in the area and it's different every time you know that code that does a generation and the static HTML code are usually in two different places, but you want to make sure that it all looks the same. You don't want that code, just because it's done dynamically, you don't want it to look ugly. So the style, the cascading style sheets allow you to apply the same style to everything, regardless of where it came from.
是的。输出格式化那么多，对吧，是的，是的，我的意思是，想象一个环境，你有几个静态的网页，它们只是 .html 文件，但你也有一些页面是生成的，嗯你知道，基于某些内容，我的意思是，也许你正在扫描天气，你正在给某人一张地图，但地图是基于该地区的天气生成的，而且每次都不一样，你知道，做生成的代码和静态 HTML 代码通常在两个不同的地方，但你想要确保它看起来都一样。你不希望那个代码，仅仅因为它被动态完成，你不希望它看起来很丑。所以样式，层叠样式表允许你把相同的样式应用到所有东西上，不管它来自哪里。
Another really useful feature is that if you've ever been to a website that allows you to choose a theme, that can be handled by choosing what CSS is loaded. So you can have a CSS that's the light blue theme or one that's the happy kitten theme. And that changes what CSS your browser uses. If you want, and this can be kind of interesting, it's like if you download an HTML page, you could change what CSS it uses and change how it looks. Or, you know, in theory, right,
另一个非常有用的功能是，如果你曾经去过一个允许你选择主题的网站，这可以通过选择加载什么 CSS 来处理。所以你可以有一个 CSS 是浅蓝色主题，或者一个是快乐小猫主题。这会改变你的浏览器使用什么 CSS。如果你愿意，这可能很有趣，就像如果你下载一个 HTML 页面，你可以改变它使用的 CSS 并改变它的外观。或者，你知道，理论上，对吧，
you could have some part of your browser that overrides the CSS referenced by an HTML and point it to something different and change how websites you use every day look and feel by writing your own CSS for it. Yep. Yeah, there's a plug-in. Most browsers will have a plug-in where it will go through
你可以有你浏览器的一部分，覆盖 HTML 引用的 CSS，并把它指向不同的东西，并通过为你自己编写 CSS 来改变你每天使用的网站的外观和感觉。是的。是的，有一个插件。大多数浏览器都会有一个插件，它会遍历
and replace the CSS links with links to CSS files on your computer, and that's mainly for development. So you could go right now to keep files on your computer, and that's mainly for development. So you could go right now to keep using the same example to AOL.com, but have it use your CSS files that are on your computer somewhere. And people from AOL would do something like this to sort of change the look and feel and do nice Qt design, make Qt design decisions without breaking the website or without having to push something out to the users. They can just test it on their own machine.
并用你电脑上的 CSS 文件的链接替换 CSS 链接，这主要是为了开发。所以你现在可以去，继续使用同一个例子，AOL.com，但让它使用你在电脑上某处的 CSS 文件。来自 AOL 的人会做这样的事情，来某种程度上改变外观和感觉，并做出好的 Qt 设计，做出 Qt 设计决策，而不破坏网站，或者不必向用户推送什么东西。他们可以在自己的机器上测试它。
Yeah, I've actually seen a couple of websites where they've asked for user feedback for people to change CSS or the style of the website. So use what they have for the default thing and then users can submit new look and feel for the website and this is one of the ways that they could do that oh interesting that's that's kind of cool actually yeah yeah yeah definitely if you've got a really involved community because it can be a lot of work yeah yeah for sure i noticed there's some frameworks that do that and so that's kind of nice because you get it for free if you're using those frameworks yeah those i guess CMS is content management systems right
是的，我实际上见过几个网站，他们要求用户反馈，让人们改变网站的 CSS 或样式。所以使用他们为默认东西拥有的东西，然后用户可以为网站提交新的外观和感觉，这是他们可以做到这一点的方法之一，哦有趣，那那其实挺酷的，是的是的是的，绝对，如果你有一个非常投入的社区，因为那可能需要很多工作，是的是的，肯定的，我注意到有一些框架这样做，所以这挺好的，因为如果你使用那些框架，你可以免费得到它，是的，那些我猜 CMS 是内容管理系统，对吧
right right um so something recently that says you might hear about is HTML has version number so most of the web nowadays uses HTML 4 but you hear about this HTML 5 what are some of the changes coming up in HTML? We talked earlier about Linux 3. HTML must be better because it's at 5. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, so we'll post a link on the blog that we'll have. It's actually called html5rocks.com,
对对，嗯，所以最近你可能会听到的一件事是 HTML 有版本号，所以现在大多数网络使用 HTML 4，但你听说过这个 HTML 5，HTML 中即将出现的一些变化是什么？我们之前谈到了 Linux 3。HTML 一定更好，因为它在 5。是的，那是对的。是的，所以我们会在博客上发布一个链接，我们会有。它实际上叫 html5rocks.com，
and it has some cool slides and some nice slick interface for showing you some of the new features. But in a nutshell, HTML works hand-in-hand with JavaScript, which we'll talk about on the next show. But what HTML5 adds is a bunch of sort of dynamic tags that add very rich content. So for example, there's a canvas tag. So you can say, you know, canvas tag, and then in there you can say box, or you could say triangle, or you could say whatever. And it'll just draw these shapes, like, right onto the website. So, you know, in the past you had to do sort of really crazy stuff, or use Flash, or use Java applets,
它有一些很酷的幻灯片和一些漂亮的流畅界面，用于向你展示一些新功能。但简而言之，HTML 与 JavaScript 手拉手工作，我们将在下一期节目中谈论它。但 HTML5 增加的是一堆某种动态标签，增加了非常丰富的内容。所以例如，有一个 canvas 标签。所以你可以说，你知道，canvas 标签，然后在那里你可以说盒子，或者你可以说三角形，或者你可以说任何东西。它就会把这些形状画出来，就像，直接画在网站上。所以，你知道，过去你必须做某种非常疯狂的事情，或者使用 Flash，或者使用 Java 小程序，
or use, you know, all sorts of different hacks, ActiveX controls, to get rich content on the Internet. And HTML5 is an attempt by a consortium of companies to say, look, we don't need all these third-party applications that are really kind of hacked together and don't work on every browser. What we really need is to just make HTML better and to make it dynamic and to make it more interactive. Yeah, and add things like the ability to embed movies directly and even have some ability to have offline storage for your website so that you can do kind of offline use of the website. For things like if you have a mail client,
或者使用，你知道，各种各样的黑客手段，ActiveX 控件，来在互联网上获得丰富的内容。而 HTML5 是一个公司联盟试图说，看，我们不需要所有这些真正某种程度上拼凑在一起且不能在每个浏览器上工作的第三方应用程序。我们真正需要的是只是让 HTML 更好，让它动态化，让它更具交互性。是的，并增加像直接嵌入电影的能力，甚至有一些能力为你的网站拥有离线存储，这样你就可以做某种离线使用网站。对于像如果你有一个邮件客户端这样的事情，
you might want to be able to browse your hotmail even when you're not connected to the Internet. You won't be able to get new stuff, but at least you could browse what you already have. Yep, that's right. So HTML has that. But with great change comes great controversy. That's right. And it's not completely settled exactly what HTML5 will end up being when it's all said and done. Yeah, one of the biggest controversies in HTML5 right now is the video encoding.
你可能想要能够浏览你的 Hotmail，即使你没有连接到互联网。你将无法获取新东西，但至少你可以浏览你已经拥有的东西。是的，那是对的。所以 HTML 有那个。但巨大的变化伴随着巨大的争议。那是对的。而且 HTML5 最终会成为什么，当一切都说完时，还没有完全确定。是的，HTML5 目前最大的争议之一是视频编码。
You know, right now there's sort of a patent war going on, as many of you know, in Silicon Valley between many different companies and consortia and uh basically where it stands right now with with the video encoding and html5 is you know the internet explorer and safari so apple's browser and uh and and microsoft's browser they support mpeg4 but mpeg4 is um covered under a. So they pay a license fee to, I believe, Frankhauser, which is a company, I believe, located based out of Germany. So they pay Frankhauser LLC to use the MPEG-4 codec. And patents are really hairy business. Technically, they're breaking the patent, but they have an agreement, so on and so forth. It's all kind of shady. So Firefox, being an open platform and being largely funded by the EFF, which we talked about, and the Free Software Foundation, which are vehemently against patents,
你知道，现在某种程度上正在发生专利战，正如你们许多人所知，在硅谷，在许多不同的公司和联盟之间，嗯，基本上它现在在视频编码和 HTML5 方面所处的位置是，你知道，Internet Explorer 和 Safari，也就是苹果的浏览器，嗯，和微软的浏览器，它们支持 MPEG4，但 MPEG4 是嗯，受 A 覆盖。所以他们支付许可费给，我相信，Frankhauser，这是一家公司，我相信，位于德国。所以他们支付 Frankhauser LLC 来使用 MPEG-4 编解码器。而专利是非常棘手的事情。从技术上讲，他们正在打破专利，但他们有一个协议，等等等等。这一切都有点阴暗。所以 Firefox，作为一个开放平台，并且很大程度上由我们谈到的 EFF 和自由软件基金会资助，它们强烈反对专利，
said, we're not going to do MPEG-4. This doesn't work. We're not happy with this. So they decided they're going to support AugTheora and another codec called the VP8 codec, which is a codec developed at Google, which is completely open source with no patent restrictions. Google Chrome, which is another browser, has jumped on the bandwagon and supports the same video codecs that Firefox supports. And so what you end up with is if you're on IE, your HTML5 videos won't work if the server expects you to be on Firefox and vice versa.
说，我们不会做 MPEG-4。这行不通。我们对此不满意。所以他们决定他们将支持 AugTheora 和另一个叫做 VP8 编解码器的编解码器，这是一个在 Google 开发的编解码器，它是完全开源的，没有专利限制。Google Chrome，这是另一个浏览器，已经加入了潮流，并支持 Firefox 支持的相同的视频编解码器。所以你最终得到的是，如果你在 IE 上，如果服务器期望你在 Firefox 上，你的 HTML5 视频将无法工作，反之亦然。
And so these kind of things always happen with new technology. There's always these battles. But eventually things will start to stabilize yeah yeah so that's my that's my soapbox for the day so there are some variants of html so we got x html yeah so these um these are very pedantic i mean this isn't the kind of thing that revolutionizes the web as much as people at the time would like venture capitalists to believe. XHTML is just a stricter formatting for HTML. So for example, in regular HTML, well, let's explain a little bit how tags work. Okay.
所以这些事情总是随着新技术发生。总是会有这些战斗。但最终事情会开始稳定，是的是的，所以那是我的每日演讲，所以有一些 HTML 的变体，所以我们有 XHTML，是的，这些嗯这些非常迂腐，我的意思是，这不是那种像当时人们希望风险投资家相信的那样彻底改变网络的东西。XHTML 只是 HTML 的更严格的格式。所以例如，在常规 HTML 中，好吧，让我们解释一下标签是如何工作的。好的。
In HTML, you have an opening tag and a closing tag So you might say opening tag table And then have opening tag row And then have opening tag cell So a table is made up of rows which are made up of cells Then you might put in some cell data Then you might say closing tag cell That's the end of that one cell Then put some more cells
在 HTML 中，你有一个开始标签和一个结束标签，所以你可能会说开始标签 table，然后有开始标签 row，然后有开始标签 cell，所以一个表格是由行组成的，行是由单元格组成的，然后你可能会放入一些单元格数据，然后你可能会说结束标签 cell，那是那个单元格的结束，然后放入更多的单元格
Open a cell, close a cell, open a cell, close a cell. Then you'll close a row. You can make some more rows. And in the end, you'll close the table. And that's the end of that table. Some of the tags in regular HTML don't have to be closed, although they really should be. So, for example, you can have a paragraph where you open the paragraph and you just don't close it. You know, you just have a paragraph, open open the paragraph and you just don't close it.
打开一个单元格，关闭一个单元格，打开一个单元格，关闭一个单元格。然后你会关闭一行。你可以制作更多的行。最后，你会关闭表格。那是那个表格的结束。常规 HTML 中的一些标签不必关闭，尽管它们确实应该关闭。所以，例如，你可以有一个段落，你打开段落，你只是不关闭它。你知道，你只是有一个段落，打开打开段落，你只是不关闭它。
You know, you just have a paragraph, open tag, you type some text, and then you have a table open tag. And browsers had to get really smart about knowing, oh, this paragraph closed because this person started a table and the table is clearly not part of that paragraph. But this got very tricky in browsers. You know, you'd go from one browser to the other and your page wouldn't work right so they decided to make HTML more strict and most web pages made nowadays are written in X HTML which adds some extra restrictions so if you open a tag you have to close it and
你知道，你只是有一个段落，开始标签，你输入一些文本，然后你有一个表格开始标签。而浏览器必须变得非常聪明，知道，哦，这个段落关闭了，因为这个人开始了一个表格，而表格显然不是那个段落的一部分。但这在浏览器中变得非常棘手。你知道，你会从一个浏览器转到另一个浏览器，而你的页面无法正常工作，所以他们决定让 HTML 更严格，现在制作的大多数网页都是用 XHTML 编写的，它增加了一些额外的限制，所以如果你打开一个标签，你必须关闭它，并且
there's a couple other restrictions but but that's the biggest one. Another buzzword is DHTML. And this basically just means using JavaScript and HTML at the same time. This is kind of a buzzword that was used. It generated a lot of hype, but it doesn't really mean anything. So don't confuse these two things with HTML5. HTML5 is huge and revolutionary. And these two things, really, they're not much of anything. So definitely be excited for HTML5.
还有几个其他限制，但那是最大的一个。另一个流行词是 DHTML。这基本上只是意味着同时使用 JavaScript 和 HTML。这是一种被使用的流行词。它产生了很大的炒作，但它并没有真正意味着什么。所以不要把这两件事和 HTML5 混淆。HTML5 是巨大的和革命性的。而这两件事，真的，它们没什么大不了的。所以一定要对 HTML5 感到兴奋。
Yeah, a lot of interesting things still coming up as far as adding animation support directly to HTML5 without using JavaScript or Flash and getting rid of more plugins to help support cross-browser compatibility hopefully it will be good but until we get there we don't know yep that's right if you do want to use the latest html5 features um i believe the development version of firefox and the current version of Chrome support just about everything.
是的，很多有趣的事情仍然会出现，就直接向 HTML5 添加动画支持而不使用 JavaScript 或 Flash，并摆脱更多的插件以帮助支持跨浏览器兼容性，希望它会很好，但在我们到达那里之前我们不知道，是的，那是对的，如果你确实想使用最新的 HTML5 功能，嗯，我相信 Firefox 的开发版本和 Chrome 的当前版本支持几乎所有东西。
There's a few things with the audio API that aren't supported with the regular version of Chrome. You have to go on the dev version. But if you use either of these two browsers, even the public versions, you'll see a lot of what HTML5 has to offer. Yeah. So besides just web pages, which is what prior to a year or two ago,
有一些关于音频 API 的东西在 Chrome 的常规版本中不支持。你必须去开发版本。但如果你使用这两个浏览器中的任何一个，即使是公共版本，你也会看到 HTML5 必须提供的很多东西。是的。所以除了网页，这是在一年或两年前之前，
most everything when you talked about HTML was talking about a web page, or I guess a few other niche uses. But now, more and more people are using HTML to do things not just in a browser on a website in the traditional sense. We talked previously about on iOS that you could have a web page show up as like an icon on your what amounts to your desktop. And you know, when you click it, it it launches and it can even launch basically a web app, a web application with a browser that you don't see so you just see the app it just runs just like a program but it's really embedded browser rendering html content for the user so think of this again to use like hotmail you could have hotmail as essentially an html that lives on the phone and some JavaScript that when you run it displays
当你谈论 HTML 时，大多数东西都在谈论网页，或者我猜还有一些其他利基用途。但现在，越来越多的人正在使用 HTML 来做不仅仅是在网站上的浏览器中做传统意义上的事情。我们之前谈到在 iOS 上，你可以让一个网页显示为像你桌面上的图标一样。而且你知道，当你点击它时，它会启动，它甚至可以基本上启动一个 Web 应用程序，一个带有你看不见的浏览器的 Web 应用程序，所以你只是看到应用程序，它就像一个程序一样运行，但它实际上是嵌入式浏览器，为用户渲染 HTML 内容，所以再想想这个，就像使用 Hotmail，你可以拥有 Hotmail，本质上是一个生活在手机上的 HTML，以及一些 JavaScript，当你运行它时，它会显示
what's local to the phone, but then has a component which can go out and grab new mail, bring that in and display that. And if it's written well enough and supports what's needed to do that, you wouldn't even be able to tell the difference between that and a program written in Objective-C for the iPhone. Yeah, I mean, you know, just take a moment. If you're looking at a web browser right now while you're watching this podcast or you can visualize one, as long as you're not driving, we don't want you to get in an accident. Yeah, don't close your eyes.
手机本地的内容，但然后有一个组件可以出去获取新邮件，把它带进来并显示出来。如果它写得足够好并且支持这样做所需的东西，你甚至无法分辨出它和为 iPhone 用 Objective-C 编写的程序之间的区别。是的，我的意思是，你知道，花点时间。如果你现在正在看这个播客时正在看网络浏览器，或者你可以想象一个，只要你不是在开车，我们不想让你发生事故。是的，不要闭上眼睛。
Yeah. Just imagine the address bar not being there and the tabs not being there and you just looking at the one page you're looking at and it's taking up the whole screen. There's really not much standing in between that, differentiating that from just a regular application. The nice thing is you can make an application that works in a browser, but then also works without a browser at the same time.
是的。只要想象地址栏不在那里，标签页也不在那里，你只是看着你正在看的那个页面，它占据了整个屏幕。真的没有太多东西站在中间，区分它和只是一个常规应用程序。好的一点是，你可以制作一个在浏览器中工作的应用程序，但同时也可以在没有浏览器的情况下工作。
This is really, for things which are largely static, this is, you know, a great way to go because you get so much for free. You know, the people who wrote the browsers kind of did the heavy lifting for you. Yeah, it's like using a really big framework or SDK or something. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, it is nice, and it really helps that if you want to run on both you know iphone and android you have a lot less work to do because now you don't have to write it in java and objectoc yeah exactly there's a web there's a application called phone gap which what
这真的，对于很大程度上是静态的东西，这是，你知道，一个很好的方式，因为你可以免费得到这么多。你知道，编写浏览器的人某种程度上为你做了繁重的工作。是的，就像使用一个非常大的框架或 SDK 之类的东西。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，它很好，而且它真的很有帮助，如果你想在 iPhone 和 Android 上运行，你有很多更少的工作要做，因为现在你不必用 Java 和 Objective-C 编写它，是的，完全正确，有一个应用程序叫 PhoneGap，它
this does is it takes a website that you've created and it will deploy it on all sorts of different environments on android ios i think it even does windows mobile and it even does uh like some of the more obscure ones like palm and things like that but basically it'll just you know take the html and javascript that you've written and do some reinterpretation as necessary to get it to be compatible with the browser on the phone and just make it an app on the phone. So, you know, you can write something once, you can test it on your computer using, you know, your web browser, and then using this PhoneGap, you just, you can deploy it and be 99% sure it's going to work on you know every smartphone out there which is
所做的是它获取你创建的网站，并将其部署在各种不同的环境中，在 Android、iOS 上，我想它甚至可以在 Windows Mobile 上运行，它甚至可以做嗯像一些更晦涩的，像 Palm 之类的，但基本上它只会，你知道，获取你编写的 HTML 和 JavaScript，并根据需要做一些重新解释，使其与手机上的浏览器兼容，并使其成为手机上的应用程序。所以，你知道，你可以写一次东西，你可以在你的电脑上使用，你知道，你的网络浏览器测试它，然后使用这个 PhoneGap，你只是，你可以部署它，并且 99% 确定它将在你知道的每一部智能手机上工作，这
which is really powerful we already kind of talked about before but uh to kind of emphasize again uh although you can write hand hand by hand write html a lot of html that you see on the web is generated from other programs written in other languages. Some of the popular ones, you know, being like PHP, Ruby on Rails, a number of Python web frameworks. Some websites actually have a C++ backend or even a C backend, which once the browser communicates with it responds with an HTML page. It's really flexibility of HTML that allows all of that to happen. And so it is used as a method of communicating what needs to be displayed. And it doesn't just have to be the traditional old school static HTML site that a person wrote by hand. Yeah, that's right.
这真的很强大，我们之前已经谈过了，但嗯为了再次强调，嗯虽然你可以手写 HTML，你在网上看到的很多 HTML 都是从用其他语言编写的其他程序生成的。一些流行的，你知道，像 PHP、Ruby on Rails、一些 Python Web 框架。一些网站实际上有一个 C++ 后端甚至一个 C 后端，一旦浏览器与它通信，它就会用一个 HTML 页面响应。这真的是 HTML 的灵活性，允许所有这些发生。所以它被用作传达需要显示什么的方法。而且它不一定非要是人手写的传统的旧式静态 HTML 网站。是的，那是对的。
I mean, imagine if you have, you know, you're writing some kind of inventory system and you have some database somewhere where every time someone buys one item it reduces that inventory by one and so then when it gets to zero it pops up it might show up in red or something like that so you might write something in Python which says hey, go to this database
我的意思是，想象一下如果你有，你知道，你正在编写某种库存系统，并且你在某处有一个数据库，每次有人购买一件商品时，它就会把那个库存减少一，所以当它变成零时，它会弹出来，它可能会以红色显示之类的，所以你可能会用 Python 写一些东西，说嘿，去这个数据库
get all the records, and for each record, convert the record into a block of HTML. So make a paragraph tag and make a little font tag for the ones that are empty and things like that. And just turn this database data into HTML code on the fly. And so if the person hits refresh on the page, after some people have gone through and bought some things they'll see the new value like the new inventory yeah yeah so i mean that's kind of a big strength and i i don't know how how much people anticipated they designed a lot of flexibility in html um but it really has survived i mean we haven't gone through any
获取所有记录，对于每条记录，把记录转换成一个 HTML 块。所以制作一个段落标签，为那些空的制作一个小字体标签之类的。并即时把这个数据库数据变成 HTML 代码。所以如果那个人点击页面上的刷新，在一些人经过并购买了一些东西之后，他们会看到新的值，比如新的库存，是的是的，所以我的意思是，这是一种巨大的优势，而且我不知道人们在设计 HTML 时预料到了多少灵活性，但它确实幸存下来了，我的意思是，我们还没有经历过任何
other real ways i mean there were early on but for a long time we've been on html and that'd be the kind of the language of the web and so the basic html has very widespread support um as long as you don't do anything weird or funny um it's really well supported it's when you get into adding plugins or javascript or other things that you can run into cross-platform issues but html itself is very cross-platform compliant yeah definitely definitely uh yeah so i guess we'll we'll cover the strengths briefly um you know as pat mentioned, it's very cross-platform. So you write the website once, and 99% of it will work on everyone's computer. And typically, when you're making websites, you're making them for a lot of people.
其他真正的方法，我的意思是早期确实有一些，但很长一段时间以来我们一直使用 HTML，它是网络语言，所以基础 HTML 有非常广泛的支持。嗯，只要你不做任何奇怪或滑稽的事情，嗯，它的支持度真的很好。当你开始添加插件、JavaScript 或其他东西时，你可能会遇到跨平台问题，但 HTML 本身是非常符合跨平台标准的。是的，绝对是，嗯，是的，所以我猜我们会简要介绍一下它的优势。你知道，正如帕特提到的，它非常跨平台。所以你写一次网站，99% 的内容都能在每个人的电脑上运行。通常，当你制作网站时，你是为很多人制作的。
I mean, imagine how many people visit, I don't know, AOL or visit any of these really popular websites, Yelp, right? I can't hash cheeseburger. I can't hash cheeseburger. I can't hash cheeseburger. Google+, right? I mean, there's millions of people going on these websites, and their computers come from all sorts of backgrounds. Some people are running Linux. Some people are running Linux kernel 3.0 beta with the latest Chrome on them.
我的意思是，想象一下有多少人访问，我不知道，AOL，或者访问任何这些非常受欢迎的网站，Yelp，对吧？Google+，对吧？我的意思是，有数百万人访问这些网站，他们的电脑来自各种背景。有些人运行 Linux。有些人运行带有最新 Chrome 的 Linux 内核 3.0 测试版。
Some people are running really old Windows 98 machines with IE6 or something, right? And so the web has to work for all of these people. Actually, it doesn't have to work for IE6 anymore. But the web has to work for a lot of these people. And the way HTML is designed it does it accomplishes this and so one of the hardest things in in you know software development is deployment you know is getting your application to run on everyone's machine anyone who's worked for a company or done commercial software development knows that there's a there's a percentage of people that you just know
有些人还在运行非常古老的 Windows 98 机器，使用 IE6 之类的浏览器，对吧？所以网络必须为所有这些人工作。实际上，它不再需要为 IE6 工作了。但网络必须为这些人中的大多数人工作。HTML 的设计方式实现了这一点，因此软件开发中最困难的事情之一就是部署，也就是让你的应用程序在每个人的机器上运行。任何在公司工作过或从事过商业软件开发的人都知道，有一部分人你从一开始就知道
upfront that you're going to have to refund them their money because the game you made isn't going to work or the app you wrote just crashes every time. This is just a known fact when you're writing desktop apps and things like that. There's going to be unsatisfied customers. When you're using HTML, the number of people who actually get your content correctly is amazing when you really think about it, all the different machines that are coming to your site. Yeah. Yeah. But the other thing is it's handwritable.
你必须退还他们的钱，因为你制作的游戏无法运行，或者你编写的应用程序每次都会崩溃。当你编写桌面应用程序等时，这是一个众所周知的事实。总会有不满意的客户。当你使用 HTML 时，真正能正确获取你内容的人数之多令人惊叹，当你真正考虑到访问你网站的所有不同机器时。是的。是的。但另一件事是它是可以手写的。
So we've talked about using programs to generate HTML, but especially for some of the static things, you might have an idea in your head of sort of how the webpage should flow and it's sort of a design, it's an aesthetic exercise in making a website. And so making something that's hand-writable where you can go in and tweak some values and maybe you want The heading bar to be a little bit smaller to give you some more real estate. You can go in and do that You don't have to Mess with some program or something to get at the HTML
所以我们谈到了使用程序来生成 HTML，但特别是对于一些静态内容，你脑子里可能对网页应该如何布局有一个想法，这是一种设计，制作网站是一种审美练习。因此，制作一些可以手写的东西，你可以进去调整一些值，也许你想要标题栏小一点以腾出更多空间。你可以进去做这些，你不必为了获取 HTML 而去摆弄什么程序之类的东西。
Yeah, typically especially with cascading style sheets. You can go in and tweak all the values and make your website look just right So some of the issues, I guess, are that HTML, plain old vanilla HTML4, doesn't really allow, we keep talking about static webpages, but HTML and CSS together don't really provide a way for animations or interactivity of any significant meaning uh right by themselves yep yeah definitely i mean we'll talk more in the next episode about javascript and ajax and things like that but but yeah i mean regular html css if you want to see something different you have to hit f5 you know or control r if you're on linux you have to hit the refresh button on your browser to get new content.
是的，通常特别是使用层叠样式表。你可以进去调整所有的值，让你的网站看起来恰到好处。所以我想，一些问题是 HTML，纯粹的老式 HTML4，并不真正允许，我们一直在谈论静态网页，但 HTML 和 CSS 结合在一起并没有真正提供任何有意义的动画或交互方式，嗯，它们本身确实不行。是的，是的，绝对，我的意思是我们在下一集中会更多地谈论 JavaScript 和 Ajax 之类的东西，但但是的，我的意思是普通的 HTML CSS，如果你想看到不同的东西，你必须按 F5，你知道，或者如果你在 Linux 上按 Ctrl R，你必须点击浏览器上的刷新按钮才能获得新内容。
Yeah. There's also, the way it's implemented now, and I know there's some movement afoot to try to fix this or change this in a number of different ways. But when you, we talked about you go request the HTML site, right? So whatever, AOL.com. And it responds with AOL.com slash index.html And you get that and your browser starts parsing it and it says oh, I need to go get this css sheet It doesn't maintain that connection. It opens a tcp connection gets to html and then closes the tcp connection So that's like a phone call picks up the phone dials says hey
是的。还有，它现在的实现方式，我知道有一些动作正在试图以多种不同的方式修复或改变这一点。但是当你，我们谈到你去请求 HTML 站点时，对吧？所以不管是什么，AOL.com。它响应 AOL.com/index.html，你得到了它，你的浏览器开始解析它，它说哦，我需要去获取这个 CSS 表。它不保持那个连接。它打开一个 TCP 连接，获取 HTML，然后关闭 TCP 连接。所以这就像一个电话，拿起电话拨号说嘿
I want the http thing here grabs it hangs up then it goes Oh, I need the css sheet picks up the phone dials says hey I want the HTTP thing here grabs it hangs up then it goes oh I need the CSS sheet picks up the phone dials the number you know asks hey I need the CSS sheet what server sends it across then it hangs up and while it's doing that the browser can optimize a little by making all of those requests in parallel but still each item is a separate tcp session and just like in that analogy of picking up the phone there's an overhead of picking it up and dialing a number and the same is true in tcp that to be flexible tcp has like a little bit of a you know slower startup time than you might want if you're going to be making many many many many requests to the
我想要这里的 HTTP 内容，抓取它，挂断，然后它说哦，我需要 CSS 表，拿起电话拨号说嘿，我想要这里的 HTTP 内容，抓取它，挂断，然后它说哦，我需要 CSS 表，拿起电话拨号，你知道，问嘿，我需要 CSS 表，服务器把它发过来，然后它挂断。当它这样做时，浏览器可以通过并行发出所有这些请求来进行一点优化，但每个项目仍然是一个单独的 TCP 会话，就像拿起电话的那个类比一样，拿起电话和拨号是有开销的，TCP 也是如此，为了灵活，TCP 的启动时间比你想要的要慢一点，如果你要进行非常非常多次的请求到
same server yeah exactly i mean just to put things in perspective, video games and things which have a high real-time component to them are done in UDP. Because UDP is another protocol, which we won't really get into, but because TCP has too much overhead, so they have to use UDP. So this, HTML is going over HTTP which has even more overhead than TCP which isn't good for a lot of applications so HTTP really isn't good for a lot of applications
同一个服务器。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，为了说明问题，具有高实时性的视频游戏等都是用 UDP 完成的。因为 UDP 是另一种协议，我们不会真正深入讨论，但因为 TCP 有太多的开销，所以他们必须使用 UDP。所以这个，HTML 是通过 HTTP 传输的，它的开销比 TCP 还要大，这对很多应用程序来说并不好，所以 HTTP 对很多应用程序来说真的不是很好
and this is the biggest weaknesses and then you know there are, as Patrick mentioned, there's, I think it's called Speedy SPDI, which is a HTTP replacement that Google Chrome has built into it. And there's, you know, other, you know, WebSockets and things like that, which are trying to sort of alleviate this problem. But, you know, for 99% of the web developers out there, this is, you know, this is a major weakness of using HTML. Yeah. And so the way that user would see that, though, is it's going to be latency. So the time you hit enter to the time they can browse your web page, and you want that to be as short as possible, because if it's too long, and we all remember the days when the transfer speed,
这是最大的弱点，然后你知道，正如帕特里克提到的，有，我想它叫 Speedy SPDI，这是 Google Chrome 内置的 HTTP 替代品。还有，你知道，其他，你知道，WebSockets 之类的东西，它们正试图缓解这个问题。但是，你知道，对于 99% 的网络开发人员来说，这是，你知道，这是使用 HTML 的一个主要弱点。是的。所以用户看到的方式是延迟。所以从你按下回车键到他们可以浏览你的网页的时间，你希望这个时间尽可能短，因为如果太长，我们都记得传输速度的那些日子，
you know, just the bandwidth to transfer all the images and text took a long time. Now we, I won't say we've completely gotten past that but now we're running into other bottlenecks which are becoming meaningful portions of the time to load a web page like these things yeah and i mean even just if it's not you know uh you know many seconds like it was back when we had modems uh we still have this issue where because you know each thing is a different request, you might go to a site and it might have, let's say, 30 images in it, but they all load at different times.
你知道，仅仅是传输所有图像和文本的带宽就需要很长时间。现在我们，我不会说我们已经完全克服了这一点，但现在我们遇到了其他瓶颈，这些瓶颈正成为加载网页时间的重要组成部分，比如这些东西。是的，我的意思是，即使不是，你知道，嗯，你知道，像我们有调制解调器时那样需要很多秒，我们仍然有这个问题，因为你知道每件事都是一个不同的请求，你可能会去一个网站，它可能有，比如说，30 张图片，但它们都在不同的时间加载。
And so there's like a second or so where you're just getting all this weird things shifting around and your browser is just, as it gets all the images, it just sort of does something crazy. And again, there's ways around this but you know by default html and css uh this is you know a big weakness once you start adding layers to to fix some of these weaknesses like add interactivity and um you know try to add animations those kind of things you start to run into the fact that although it was a strength that html is cross-platform you also have the fact that people are running browsers that are 10 years old and you know eight years old and i saw a really
所以有一秒左右的时间，你只是得到所有这些奇怪的东西在移动，你的浏览器只是，当它得到所有图像时，它只是做了一些疯狂的事情。同样，有办法解决这个问题，但你知道默认情况下 HTML 和 CSS，嗯，这是一个，你知道，一旦你开始添加层来修复其中一些弱点，比如添加交互性和，嗯，你知道，尝试添加动画之类的东西，你就会开始遇到这样一个事实，尽管 HTML 是跨平台的是一个优势，但你也有这样一个事实，人们运行的是 10 年前，你知道，8 年前的浏览器，我看到一个非常
good graph about this once for each of the major uh each of the major web browsers how many people are still using old versions but uh corporations don't necessarily want to roll up the latest and greatest thing because it's an unknown you've got you know your grandmother who doesn't know how to update her internet explorer and so if windows doesn't tell her to do it she's not going to do it and so you've got people using really old browsers which may have bugs or problems and so you can get as you build up complexity you get all these weird rendering issues and you have to check compatibility across, you know, more than just four or five, you know, probably 10 or 15 different browser and browser version numbers to really, if you want to make sure you get all of your users the same experience yeah so it's not uncommon for a web developer to use virtual box which i think we talked about virtual box is one of the tools of the bi-week yeah so it's not uncommon to have virtual box with you know a windows xp machine with ie6 a windows xp machine
好的关于这个的图表，对于每个主要的，嗯，每个主要的网络浏览器，有多少人还在使用旧版本，但是，嗯，公司不一定想升级到最新最好的东西，因为它是未知的。你有，你知道，你的祖母不知道如何更新她的 Internet Explorer，所以如果 Windows 不告诉她这样做，她就不会这样做，所以你有很多人在使用非常旧的浏览器，这些浏览器可能有错误或问题，所以当你增加复杂性时，你会得到所有这些奇怪的渲染问题，你必须检查兼容性，你知道，不仅仅是四五个，你知道，可能是 10 或 15 个不同的浏览器和浏览器版本号，如果你想确保你给所有的用户同样的体验。是的，所以网络开发人员使用 VirtualBox 并不罕见，我想我们谈到了 VirtualBox 是双周工具之一。是的，所以拥有一个带有，你知道，带有 IE6 的 Windows XP 机器，一个 Windows XP 机器
with ie7 windows xp machine with ie8 etc etc and to have all of these virtual computers all with different virtual browsers and to try your website on all of them and see what the happens. It's not uncommon actually it's almost guaranteed that you'll write a website
带有 IE7 的 Windows XP 机器，带有 IE8 的 Windows XP 机器等等，并且拥有所有这些带有不同虚拟浏览器的虚拟计算机，并在所有这些计算机上尝试你的网站，看看会发生什么，这并不罕见。实际上，这几乎是肯定的，你会写一个网站
with Chrome or with Firefox or with Internet Explorer in mind, and then you'll go to one of the other browsers and it won't look right. I mean, something will look different. Maybe the text is just big enough where it causes everything to sort of collapse further down in the page, and you'll have to go in and make tweaks. You'll have to say in your CSS, you'll have to say, if this is IE8 do this or in your
考虑到 Chrome、Firefox 或 Internet Explorer，然后你会去其他浏览器之一，它看起来就不对了。我的意思是，有些东西看起来会不同。也许文本只是大到足以导致页面上的所有东西都进一步向下折叠，你必须进去进行调整。你必须在你的 CSS 中说，你必须说，如果是 IE8 就这样做，或者在你的
HTML you'll have to write some JavaScript it says you know if this is you know Chrome you have to make this setting otherwise make that setting yeah there are some tools out there to help with those kinds of things like I know there's some services cropping up to have a bunch of basically like you said VirtualBox instances where they run your website and then send you pictures of all of the results or at least pictures pictures of the ones that they've detected to have rendered differently oh that's really cool yeah i've never heard of that but that's awesome yeah there's some people trying to do that it's very cool yeah i mean he's genius
HTML 中你必须写一些 JavaScript，它说，你知道，如果是 Chrome，你必须进行这个设置，否则进行那个设置。是的，有一些工具可以帮助解决这类事情，比如我知道有一些服务正在涌现，基本上就像你说的 VirtualBox 实例，它们运行你的网站，然后把所有结果的图片发给你，或者至少是它们检测到渲染不同的那些图片。哦，那太酷了。是的，我从来没听说过，但这太棒了。是的，有些人正在尝试这样做，非常酷。是的，我的意思是他是天才
because that way they just have the virtual boxes up all the time. And as soon as you give them a website, they go and visit it. So it's really cool. Yeah, I guess the only other weakness I can think of is just the verbosity of HTML. So when the HTTP protocol does have compression standards built in. So it will automatically compress your HTTP content before it sends it over the wire. So you don't have to worry about doing that. But even in compressed form, it's a description of what the webpage should look like. And so the tags are very verbose and you're having a lot of these opening and closing tags all over the place.
因为这样他们就一直开着虚拟机。一旦你给他们一个网站，他们就会去访问它。所以这真的很酷。是的，我想我能想到的唯一其他弱点就是 HTML 的冗长。所以当 HTTP 协议确实内置了压缩标准时。所以它会在通过网络发送之前自动压缩你的 HTTP 内容。所以你不必担心这样做。但即使在压缩形式下，它也是对网页应该是什么样子的描述。所以标签非常冗长，你到处都有很多这些开始和结束标签。
So you might want to just have a little table with some text in each of the cells and you might, if you're writing in C or something like that, you might just say, look, at this position put this text, at this position put that text. But because you're writing in HTML and it has to sort of conform to all these browsers and it has to look nice on all these different computers you have to be sort of very generic and say I want this table and I want this row and column
所以你可能只想有一个小表格，每个单元格里有一些文本，如果你是用 C 或类似的东西编写的，你可能只是说，看，在这个位置放这个文本，在这个位置放那个文本。但因为你是在用 HTML 编写，它必须符合所有这些浏览器，并且它必须在所有这些不同的计算机上看起来不错，你必须非常通用，说我想要这个表格，我想要这一行和这一列
and it ends up becoming very verbose yeah and not only in data overhead of sending all that redundant information across but trying to fix a problem and go through all of these tags and parameters and and stuff to try to find where the problem might be can be a little overwhelming if you're trying to debug like a static html page by hand or trying to debug the output of uh you know a machine generated html page yeah i mean a lot of people say that the uh you know the modern internet was built on the back
结果变得非常冗长。是的，不仅是在发送所有这些冗余信息的数据开销方面，而且试图解决问题并检查所有这些标签和参数等以试图找到问题可能在哪里，如果你试图手动调试静态 HTML 页面或试图调试机器生成的 HTML 页面的输出，可能会有点让人不知所措。是的，我的意思是很多人说，嗯，你知道，现代互联网是建立在
of firebug which is um a extension or maybe it's built into firefox i think it's a i think it's a plugin oh okay still an extension yeah but uh they uh you know what it does is it will actually you can click on something while you have this firebug running and it will sort of show you what the HTML is because you might have a program as we mentioned generating HTML on the fly and let's say you had a bug in that program your output is just going to be a bunch of HTML so you might end up with garbage HTML or you might end up with lines being colored red even though they shouldn't be and this firebug lets you sort of go inside and say, what does this HTML look like at this particular spot?
Firebug 的基础上的，它是一个扩展，或者也许它是内置在 Firefox 中的，我想它是一个插件。哦，好的，仍然是一个扩展。但是，嗯，它们，你知道它所做的是它实际上你可以点击某些东西，当你运行这个 Firebug 时，它会向你展示 HTML 是什么，因为你可能有一个程序，正如我们提到的，在运行中生成 HTML，假设你的程序中有一个错误，你的输出只是一堆 HTML，所以你最终可能会得到垃圾 HTML，或者你可能会得到即使不应该被着色的行被着色为红色，这个 Firebug 让你进去说，这个 HTML 在这个特定点看起来是什么样的？
So I think Chrome has something similar called Inspector, which is built into Chrome. You can just right click and say Inspect Element. And you can do this right now even if you're using Chrome. And it'll sort of show you the html that was generated for that particular element very cool very cool yeah yeah so html css i mean the technology started a long time ago but it's still very applicable to today it's still used it's the language of the web and very although it may not be directly a programming language, certainly it'll be a valuable experience for our listeners to learn some more about it. Yeah, definitely. I mean, I think that the Internet is really, you know, they always say, I think Larry Page is quoted as saying, never bet against the internet and uh you know what he's insinuating
所以我认为 Chrome 有一个类似的东西叫 Inspector，它是内置在 Chrome 中的。你现在就可以右键点击并说检查元素。即使你正在使用 Chrome，你现在也可以这样做。它会向你展示为该特定元素生成的 HTML。非常酷，非常酷。是的，是的，所以 HTML CSS，我的意思是这项技术很久以前就开始了，但它今天仍然非常适用，它仍然被使用，它是网络的语言，虽然它可能不是直接的编程语言，但对我们的听众来说，学习更多关于它的知识肯定是一次宝贵的经验。是的，绝对。我的意思是，我认为互联网确实是，你知道，他们总是说，我想拉里·佩奇曾引用过一句话，永远不要与互联网对赌，嗯，你知道他在暗示什么
is that the the internet is really uh because of the way it's just so distributed in nature and the way you can broadcast content out to hundreds or thousands or millions or billions of people it's really a just an amazing medium for getting information out there. And so this is HTML and CSS are your paint brushes and pencils that you use to sort of create in this medium. So this is the first of two, you know, podcasts on this topic. In the next show, we'll talk about JavaScript, which is a way to sort of add dynamic content and make your page
是互联网确实是，因为它的本质是如此分布式的，以及你可以将内容广播给成百上千、成千上万、数百万或数十亿人的方式，它确实是一个传播信息的惊人媒介。所以这是 HTML 和 CSS 是你在这个媒介中用来创作的画笔和铅笔。所以这是关于这个主题的两个播客中的第一个。在下一期节目中，我们将讨论 JavaScript，这是一种添加动态内容并使你的页面
change on the fly um but yeah i mean this is definitely where it all started and this isn't going away so you said next episode next episode is going to be episode number 10 that's right it's a milestone the double digits pretty awesome yeah it's been enjoyable so far um you know typically wrap up the show talking about how things are going. So like I said, we've gotten some people following us on Google+. That's been really nice and encouraging and awesome. Hopefully we can get a dialogue going there. As always, make sure you can visit the blog for show notes and, you know, able to download the podcast there as well.
即时改变的方法。嗯，但是的，我的意思是这绝对是这一切开始的地方，而且这不会消失。所以你说下一集，下一集将是第 10 集，没错，这是一个里程碑，两位数，非常棒。是的，到目前为止很愉快。嗯，你知道通常在节目结束时谈论事情进展如何。所以就像我说的，我们有一些人在 Google+ 上关注我们。这真的很不错，令人鼓舞，而且很棒。希望我们能在那里进行对话。像往常一样，确保你可以访问博客获取节目笔记，并且，你知道，也可以在那里下载播客。
And that's programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com you can also email us at programmingthrowdown at gmail.com yeah i mean if you have any you know questions or uh you know uh you know feedback on the podcast or if you if you have any programming questions you know let's say you want to know about something in particular like game design or you want to know about data structures, I don't know, anything that kind of piques your curiosity and you want us to sort of elucidate more information on. That is not a problem. So yeah, we're definitely, you know, there's no shortage of programming languages, as I'm sure you guys know out there by now. But if there's a particular one that you're interested in that we haven't covered yet, definitely shoot us an email and let us know. Yeah, well, if that's it, I guess we'll wrap it up.
那是 programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com，你也可以通过 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com 给我们发电子邮件。是的，我的意思是如果你有任何，你知道，问题，或者，嗯，你知道，关于播客的反馈，或者如果你有任何编程问题，你知道，假设你想了解特定的东西，比如游戏设计，或者你想了解数据结构，我不知道，任何能激发你好奇心并希望我们阐明更多信息的东西。那没问题。所以是的，我们绝对，你知道，编程语言并不短缺，我相信你们现在都知道了。但如果我们还没有涵盖你感兴趣的特定语言，一定要给我们发电子邮件告诉我们。是的，好吧，如果就是这样，我想我们会结束它。
Thank you all for listening. Yeah, have a good week. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家的收听。是的，祝大家有个愉快的一周。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。